By herself in a house.
Like she should series.
The thing about buying a house,
Jamie and me,
you yes.
Are you should fear in the fucking
house.
So we feel like we're doing something.
There we go.
These headphones make a difference.
It's so much easier without glasses.
They used to pinch me.
Oh,
that's right.
Crush my ears just went and got your
eyes cut on.
They put a fucking laser right to your
eyeball and they go,
don't look at it.
I'm like,
it's IRA.
I Blah.
Oh Wow.
Because you're looking at him like,
I know I'm looking at it,
it's right in my eyeball.
So what do you have to do?
What?
Which one are you ready to head?
And so they come in like this looks,
but then it's like right as it gets
right into your eyes,
slightly to the left.
Like it goes to like the outside of the,
the black part,
you know.
How do they keep your eyeballs opened
from blinking?
Uh,
um,
what's it called?
Style.
Like a speculum.
Yeah,
but what's that movie?
Clockwork.
Yeah.
They do that to,
you know,
really hitting you with drops to like
wet it.
Oh my God.
That they peel back the layer like a
grape,
you know,
like the show up rate.
How does that feel?
Nothing.
It doesn't feel like anything.
You can't really feel it whoa.
Later.
It feels like,
cause it's like a slight scar that has
to heal.
But you're not used to having a scar
between your eyelid in your eyeball.
So it feels like a piece of sand is in
there and they're like,
do not rub it.
There's no sand in there.
Just don't rub it.
I balls or some fucking serious shit.
It's one of the most disturbing things
to me about mma is I pokes when guys
get,
I poked almost I'd to,
I'd rather see a guy get hit real hard.
They didn't get I poked.
That was the worst thing of on a game of
thrones.
Oh God,
dude crushed him with two I boiler
alert,
whatever spoiler stuff that's five years
old.
It's not that I knew show was like three
or four years old dude who got smushed.
It was bad ass ass.
I wanted to win so bad.
He had so much going for him so much.
He was going to get revenge.
Finally he had flare,
he had technique.
He was a bisexual.
Yeah,
but they all were back then.
Man.
People just fucked everybody back.
Then there's like,
there's so much of a different world.
If we think about like what the Romans
did and what all these different
cultures did,
they were like fucking each other.
Fucking young boys like young boys.
It was normal for guys to fuck young
boy.
Like what the hell?
Better World.
Right?
It's fucking strange when you go back
and you listen to like,
it was plato,
right?
Plato was one of the big ones.
The big boy fuckers wasn't he fucker.
I think polito was a soldier.
He uh,
he was uh,
like a,
a warrior,
like accomplished warrior then
philosopher.
Yeah.
If I'm remembering this story correctly,
which we're pretty fucking high,
right?
Which is probably wrong high right now
and it's awakened big day.
Has this pet or have you heard that
term?
What does that,
when I googled him and boys,
that's what comes up.
So what does a better us?
It means someone who likes to fuck young
boys.
It's bizarre that that was like really
commonplace amongst very respected
intellectuals at one point in human
history played or didn't lose his
fucking subway campaign.
You could go on big philosophers in
history.
Yeah,
you don't take it away.
If they're dead and it's a long time
ago,
we set,
well,
I mean we should,
right?
Because he had a lot to contribute.
We should,
we should accept aberrant behavior,
but we should also maybe look at it as a
sign of,
there's some,
there's massive advancement and
understanding about human beings,
about the consequences of sexual abuse,
like all those things,
like I don't think they really had
enough time to live to figure things out
enough.
Everyone's was dead at 30 right.
There's going to fuck them up as adults.
I'm like,
wait,
what did you,
how fucking stupid this country is,
right.
How ridiculous we are if we look at each
other as a collective.
When you find out things that people get
upset with something or tweeted today
about this,
was it chase,
whatever,
whatever bank it was,
they wouldn't allow a guys checked.
They canceled his check because he wrote
dash on it,
which is his fucking dogs name Dash and
they thought dash was too close to an
Islamic word,
which is like a d a.
E.
S.
A.
Where did he write it on it?
He wrote it on a check like two.
It's fucking dog.
Where's this money going?
Note to south dog might like maybe just
dog got out of the memo.
Pus some,
some part of it like pull it up Jamie.
Cause I thought it was in his lap
mcmahon.
That was the reason they can't you send
something to a guy named I met exactly.
What if the guy's name is Muhammad or we
fucked.
Now how does Mohammad Ali get his checks
out of the homiletic bank?
Freezes online payment over Doug's
terrorist sounding name.
Po.
Can you scroll it so we could see what
the words are because it's hurting my
brain.
I have a picture of her.
You guys trying to find the picture and
here's the young guy he's got,
he's got to think he's got,
um,
that makes them get more sympathy for
sure.
The scroll up went noose.
What was his disease?
Jamie?
I want to see,
yeah,
multiple sclerosis.
He was transferring money from his chase
account.
Whose dog?
Walker.
So he put the nine year old pitbulls
moniker dash in the memo line because
this is to pay for his fucking dog
Walker.
Yeah.
And it's too much like d a.
E.
S.
H the Arabic term for self described
Islamic state.
That's their word for isis.
Yes.
I guess.
But it's not the same word.
You fucks.
That's like you,
you can't write nagger explain what
someone's that nags.
You can't write that.
Oh,
is it because I mean donating money to
isis and he's like,
uh,
hold on.
Yes,
exactly.
They thought for some reason that that
was a red flag or you're not allowed to
give money to isis.
I don't think you're allowed to look at
it.
Says it says it flagged a payment,
which place to note on Francis Account
asking him to explain what dash
explaining yourself son,
God dammit soldiers died.
But it's the,
it's not the same word,
like think of how many words day die.
I mean does it w w w w what are we going
to da e s h is not the same as d a s.
H,
right?
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
It's just not the same word.
Like we have combinations of words that
are vastly different.
So this is one extra letter.
Yes,
it is a word and it means to go fast.
It everybody knows it.
It's so stupid.
I mean,
you think there's so many different
combinations that you can say our close
flagged reviewed and eventually released
out an hour.
What about that other,
the same thing?
Is it the same word?
Should we flag it?
Is it the same?
What do you mean?
Did you mean out or hour?
I wrote out,
I wrote out you fuck.
Well,
yes,
but we would like to know if you met
our,
well,
I woulda wrote our,
oh,
go out.
You fucks.
Okay.
That's cleared up,
but I don't think you have to call us
fucks by you.
Why are you contacting me?
This is not what you're supposed to do.
We supposed to do is pay my goddamn dog
walker so I don't look like a dickhead.
So she's got a pair of fucking rent and
you ruined everything.
Sorry,
I understand you're upset,
but if you're just calm down,
we're trying to stop terrorism.
It's fucking the Rothschild's or some
shit.
Chem trails sort of.
If you could watch a longer scenes and
nine 11 all together with the fucking
moon landing and area 51 bullshit.
I want my fucking money.
She's a great dog.
Ever lose it on a customer service
person.
I'm like,
that is fucking go nuts.
I'm not like that.
I try.
I try to be,
I hate those jobs.
I wouldn't want that job.
They don't want that job.
I tried to be,
I know it's not never their fault.
I try to be as nice as possible.
Some people are just so,
it's not even their fault.
Something people that you talk to like
customer service people are so like if,
if it's for something Shitty,
like something that happens all the
time,
like they're dealing with so many people
that are complaining all the time.
Oh right.
Yeah.
I remember when apples,
uh,
Robert,
the iphone,
oh yeah.
End Up,
you know,
18th he only had it drops,
calls were dropped left and right
because everyone had gone on there and I
was like,
what's up?
He goes,
I was like,
Hey,
you must deal with a lot of calls about
drop calls.
Like it's a lot.
It's a lot of angry people.
I remember I had a guy talked me through
some issue on my phone once I had to
call a dude.
I don't remember what the exact issue
was,
but like all my contacts went away.
I was like,
what is going on here?
And he had to talk me through it and
figure out how to get it back to the way
it used to be an update things.
So it was,
it was a nightmare.
But I remember the guy while I was like,
dude,
okay,
how much does this job suck?
Like go,
I'm not completely retarded and you're
trying to help me through this.
And I've built computers.
I,
I've taken a
motherboard,
I put it in,
I put the seat,
I put the heat sink in,
and I've done all that added video
cards.
I know a little bit about computers,
just,
I mean,
I'm not like a computer wizard,
but long,
average retard.
Right?
And I was barely figuring it out.
I was like,
okay,
I gotta go back.
I got to delete.
What do I do?
I start fresh.
Okay.
I go to my backup.
I have a backup.
I was at with the key law.
Well,
where did they go?
Where's all my contacts go?
Why did they get chewed up like this?
I don't know anybody's,
fuck,
I don't know your number.
You're the same number forever.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
I just look at my phone,
I find your number and I call you.
And um,
but I remember talking to the guy going
like,
what is this like,
man?
He's like,
dude,
I can't even describe it.
He's like,
people call up you like if you ever even
see if you have a phone or a video or
are you just crazy?
They say,
he says to them,
he wants to say to them like,
do you know how to be like,
okay,
did you turn it on
but the phone's black.
I saw somebody in the airport doing that
but on a call like I don't understand.
How do you get the thing to send and I
want to be like,
Hey lady,
that send button at the bottom is what
you're looking for.
Sometimes it talks to me.
That's that Siri,
ma'am,
why does Siri,
what is theory?
Is it important what they're saying?
Did you say,
Hey Siri,
what the fuck are you?
I don't know what I said.
Phone is talking to me is a bigger issue
when you say,
Hey Siri,
Hey Siri.
I like me saying this right now.
Over and over again.
People right now,
all across the world are yelling at me.
He'd get mad,
they get mad cause it start.
Your phone starts talking to you like it
happened to me when I was in my car
listening to a podcast of us talk to you
about,
Hey Siri,
my phone went off because the podcast
said,
Hey Siri.
So my phone started asking me what can I
do for you?
I was like,
oh my God,
this is ridiculous.
And sometimes it starts transcribing
things sometimes.
Like,
Hey,
Siri will activate and then it'll
transcribe a whole list of shit that
you're saying.
Wow.
Yeah.
I'm like,
what do you do?
That's not my question.
Like,
Hey,
Siri thinks you have like a four
paragraph long question for it.
So you're just like,
oh hey Siri,
look up hardcore black and white
pornography.
I'm a different person at work.
I don't even care about those things.
Work
at work.
I wear a suit and I have very special
behavior.
I'm a different person here.
I am.
I different.
I used to,
I used to wear my yarmulke up,
my law firm.
I worked at it as a,
it's like a 1718 year olds and um,
and then I would take it out.
What would I do?
Owe a lot of guys,
law lawyers were coming in to take the
Yamaka office and as I got
in,
because I wanted to blend in,
but I would keep mine on whatever,
but the next year I lost my religion and
then I didn't want to explain to
everybody that I did wasn't religious
anymore.
So I would come in,
put my Yamaka on and then as soon as I
left I would just take it off again.
Ooh,
that's a good mood.
Yeah.
For a whole summer.
That's a better move than explaining it.
Yeah.
Planning.
It is a lot of work.
That's how much I had to every person.
It's the same explanation,
but if you worked in a small office with
people that you really liked,
it wouldn't be that big.
It was four or five people.
Who are one sec guys.
Uh,
sorry.
I realized I was all bullshit.
Hey he fella.
Where's your special hat?
We had a lady follow us up once on the
elevator telling you and this other guy
were like,
what?
Flora?
And she goes up,
do you accept the Lord Jesus Christ as
your personal savior?
I don't know what floor.
That's,
Huh.
I was like,
shoot,
didn't even,
wasn't even going there.
She followed us.
We were going for lunch.
She came back and followed up at the
elevator.
Just don't do that.
What's worse?
Dem vegans
like for proselytizing?
Who's the co who hits you the hardest?
At the heart of it,
they see Jesus freaks.
Just want to help your soul.
Right.
Good call.
What does what of vegans want?
They want the animals.
Yeah.
And now not at the heart of it.
They both want to feel better than you.
Yes.
Yeah.
Michael Shermer calls it virtue
signaling.
You met Michael Shermer.
Yeah.
He's,
he's the best.
Yeah.
He was on a couple of weeks ago.
Great Guy.
Real Nice Guy.
Like very fun to talk to a wise man.
Yeah.
Because it virtue signaling.
It's a great way of describing me.
You're signaling to everyone that you
have virtue by your action.
Peacocking your virtue,
you know,
and uh,
it,
it annoys the fuck out of people.
Yeah.
It's gross.
Like from,
from all sorts of different standpoints.
Not just about your diet,
but about a lot of different things.
New Aa people are like that.
Yeah.
New Aa.
People who love Yoga people could be
like that.
I've been guilty.
Really guilty or that I'm annoying.
I just feel so clear now.
I,
yeah,
I'm annoying with that.
Oh,
I used to give me a gluten free gluten
free work for a little while.
Here's what the gluten free taught
taught me.
Um,
I don't really have a tolerance problem
to gluten,
but gluten is essentially sugar.
When you,
when you're getting gluten,
you're getting getting it from bread and
gluten is like a protein.
Wheat bread is fucking sugar.
Yeah.
Sugar.
I go without,
um,
without sugar on Wednesdays.
And then,
uh,
Mike vacuum was like pizza,
but that just turns to sugar in your
body.
But shut up scientist.
I'm not talking about that.
I cut all that stuff out too.
And sugar.
Yeah.
Wow.
No Pizza.
Nope.
No,
I don't need it anymore.
He didn't eat that bread last night.
Talking to all those door guys.
Devour the leftovers.
It's pounds of meat.
Yeah.
There's this place called doctor uglies,
Tyler,
Texas barbecue.
And it's out in Van Nuys,
California and is my all time favorite
barbecue spot in California for sure.
One.
And what's one of the best in the
country?
It's amazing cause those ribs look like
fucking flintstones.
Yup.
There were massive,
super legit too.
Like the paneling on the wall is like
shitty fake wood.
It's been the same way since 1974 it's
just,
it's just classic.
It is a classic restaurant.
It is Americana and they give you an
insane portion of me.
So much meat.
I can't believe I the way that that,
okay,
that was a,
that's a try.
Those,
what does it shows three different
things.
That was triple Combo.
Triple Combo.
You had beef ribs,
so you had spare ribs and yet Greski
obviously brisket,
you can't go to a barbecue.
What's it like having the brisket?
If you've got a combo,
it's hard and brisk and figure out what
else do you want.
Yeah,
that was 23 bucks.
It's nice,
but it wasn't even that much.
It's insane amount of food because
that's easily enough food for three
people,
like we pigged out and eat it all.
But three reasonable people that place
for me.
And plus they give you sides.
What are we doing?
A commercial for?
Animals die for that.
She didn't even tell everybody about it.
I don't want anybody to know.
Why do one do well?
What are the best barbecues you've ever,
there's a bunch of good spots in Texas.
There's a bunch of good spots outside of
Austin Franklin.
Uh,
I've been the one outside of us,
but Franklin in Austin,
Franklin Barbecue is supposed to be
insane.
Yeah.
And the cool thing is,
so the lines are coming down the street.
The first time I went,
it was raining.
I got lucky.
I waited for an hour and a half.
Uh,
totally worth it.
Why?
Because it was raining because it was
right there.
And they,
uh,
they said everybody come on and off the
street,
get under the cover,
we'll go.
They're all cool people.
But industry has risen up around that
line.
Like that is task rabbit people.
They'll wait in line for you for 20
bucks,
but now they're onto them.
So like,
you can only order for up to like four
people a fucking chair.
Salesmen's they have rental chairs up in
line.
Just waiting there like,
hey,
well I can make money.
Does it find a chair for you and the
line moves?
No,
I think you got to come up,
pick it up and I know you should get up
and they should move his boy.
You like you're royalty.
Yeah,
I would love that.
That'd be right.
They come out and sell beer,
so I know how weird.
It's so weird,
but it's so fucking good that brisket
melts in your mouth.
Like it's,
it's just like,
it's like cotton candy.
This is another place in Austin that
Aubrey swears by two,
I don't remember.
Yeah,
he lives in Austin.
Yeah.
There's another place that he says is
just as good,
but it's not a scene.
Santa suit.
Well,
something that got popular got on TV,
right?
It got an Anthony Bourdain show.
Well,
he would trade with the other guy who
used to be the best guy in Austin.
This got trained with him,
got his own smoker.
It was just in a back parking lot.
That's what they do.
They go pack parking lot.
So the first time I went,
I just,
I looked for one,
I was like,
ah,
molars,
Mueller,
Mueller's barbecue.
And I went in there at like 1230,
no lines.
Like,
oh,
it was cool.
Great.
I was like,
Hey,
can I get some?
Uh,
and they're like,
what are you sold out of me in a long
time ago?
Signed,
you've got to get here early.
They sell at a meet at certain times.
At some point the line for Franklin to
go,
no more Turkey,
just so you guys know.
And then 10 minutes later,
no more prestigious.
And I'm like,
AH,
Fuck Jews.
They only have meat enough for that day.
So by two,
they're closed.
Their dealers,
their dealers,
their dealers and getting you out it
creating a surplus.
They got a line of people.
Yeah.
It's,
it's amazing.
it's a cool,
but then they do like,
oh,
we got to where they had it.
So they had that smoker in the back
parking lot somewhere and then they had
to find a buyer place.
They literally have an over abundance of
buyers.
They have too much.
Yeah.
Like they,
they keep their business exactly as big
as it is,
but they haven't,
they haven't expanded.
Wow.
That's so rare.
Perfect.
Yeah.
It's so rare though,
right?
It's,
it's glorious.
It's very rare.
It's very,
just say something like,
Oh,
I'm just going to keep running this
business where I can keep my eye on
everything.
We can do it the right way.
They give you brisket in line,
like a Katz's Deli.
Oh really?
You know with the Pastrami,
they'll like taste this,
you know?
They walked by with some,
just as you get to the front,
they just cut you off some test,
which are about to order.
Oh,
that's good.
Yeah.
They did that to us in this place that
we went to.
Me And ben and Aubrey went to this
place.
It's about 40 minutes outside of Austin.
I forget the name of it.
Yeah.
I went there.
Yes.
You've been to.
That's what there with Metzger and a few
of the people I met Scott in the last
brisket and we all had a fucking suck up
on some goddamn Turkey to hot legs,
peasant immigrants.
He didn't split the brisket with him.
No,
he did not.
Wow.
That's not a kind person.
He's selfish.
That's dark and he's taking his time.
There's three of you and you guys like
seven of us.
Okay.
Fuck them.
Yeah.
How many people?
You guys can all have a lick of one
bite.
The problem is you roll too deep.
Yeah,
because that's just too much brisket to
hang around.
All those different folks.
It's like,
sorry,
we should've gotten there earlier.
What I was getting to earlier was that,
think about that.
Who Guy,
that dash thing about how stupid that is
that this is in 2016 with the world that
we live in today,
these kind of morons are still making
decisions.
Some six year old girl got arrested for
stealing candy to put her in handcuffs.
See that six years old heard her
handcuffs,
scared straight stuff.
Had to be that no cop is going to look
it up.
A girl.
I go like,
we really got to take her in.
I don't know,
but it wasn't a white girl for sure.
It wasn't,
obviously it wasn't a white car.
Isn't that,
I mean you,
could you even imagine that taking
college or not?
When a went to a white girl?
No,
that's crazy.
Young Lady Racist.
Oh yeah,
that's crazy.
Off the top racist.
Oh,
she's so cute.
Over the top races.
Chicago mom,
outrage after daughter's six placed in
handcuffs for taking candy,
taking any of the teachers that I
thought maybe there was some Persian guy
who was like,
no,
she stares.
You'll go that law.
And then I had to be like a restaurant
on arrest her.
But if it's off a teacher's desk,
we're trying to teach her a lesson.
It says,
yeah,
you're gonna wind up in jail.
What the fuck man?
That his crew,
so this is the world we're living in
today,
right?
This is how crazy some of the stories
are where this gets through somehow or
this becomes a real thing.
This actually happens.
And then we're all talking about it.
Like what in the fuck in imagine life
back when most people died at like 24
like everybody's dead.
Half the people that like your,
you give birth to half of them die.
They just don't make it.
Like when you were looking at the ages
of people that lived back in during the
Roman times,
I mean,
what is the end?
I think the infant mortality rate back
then was something insane,
like 40% or something like that.
This is what I don't,
I lose.
I lose what parents say.
Which you say I'm more angry than
anything because my only daughter,
I feel like anything could have happened
to her.
Somebody could have touched her.
She in the dark under the stairs,
but that's just ridiculous.
You know what that is?
That's someone that sees the finish
line.
You have no money.
Why?
Why would,
why would you think anyone's going to
touch her under the stairs at school?
Because she's scared.
I mean,
who knows?
She might not be that bright.
Who the fuck knows?
But she also was being interviewed so
she sees the finish line.
The finish line is you got to make this
traumatic as fuck to get that big paper.
She's getting some pig.
Oh,
she's trying to do that.
Oh fuck yeah,
she's Gunna Dude.
I mean,
if there's ever been a slam dunk case,
if I was an ambulance chaser or a one of
those asshole guys,
it looks to sue over nothing on this
thing.
This one's crazy.
Can we talk to you real quick?
Yeah.
This one's fucking crazy.
You handcuffed to a six year old girl.
I got read to teach someone a lesson
though.
I sort of get it on that level.
No Baker scare.
You don't steal.
We don't still know how to put kids in
chains.
Oh,
you had cheese.
Not you're just not.
You're definitely not allowed to do a
deal.
A little black kid because of the
connotations.
Yeah,
just can't do it.
You can't take a six year old and go,
this is what you're going to be.
So the teacher,
she's a little kid,
man.
Let me tell you something,
dude.
I've a teacher or a cop.
No one's fault.
It's part of being a kid.
Kids do stupid shit in the handcuffs.
The teacher who said,
oh,
whoever put the handcuffs on her for
sure is the culprit.
Whoever put the handcuffs on her,
whoever would a man that put that,
I assume it's a man who's cinched up
those handcuffs around that six year old
risks.
Get the fuck Outta here.
They'll see.
First of all,
you should never be a cop for the rest
of your life ever if you can't control a
six year old security guard,
but still,
okay.
Same thing.
Paul blart some Paul blart type
character.
If it's nonsense,
man,
I still,
my,
uh,
my cousin's comb out of his desk,
Israel and my dad saw it cause we're,
where'd you get this call?
And had a cool pony picture on it,
on a cone was a Palomino.
And uh,
I was like,
Oh God,
he's quitting mean you don't have any
money.
You don't get things other God,
you've got this fucking time,
man.
What are you talking about?
You've got it.
And I was like,
I got it from a,
he goes room.
He was like,
did he give it to?
And I was like,
no.
He found out I was going,
you got to go back there and tell him he
stole it.
And I was like,
aw man,
please do not make me do.
It's like,
yeah,
it don't want it.
I've got buses see on the top bar once.
Really?
Yeah.
I think I was 12 like 11 or 12 maybe
somewhere that age.
Who busted you?
Security.
Okay.
Security Guard at a store.
I put like a candy bar in my pocket or
something.
I've don't exactly remember how it went
down,
but I remember the guy grabbing me on my
shoulder.
I was like an slick about it,
you know,
really unsafe.
Lik I think it was probably 11.
They're already watching you and you
don't remember.
Um,
yeah,
it was fucking ridiculous.
And um,
and then they take in some rooms,
scare the shit out of here.
You know,
you ever do this again?
We're going to call the police.
We're going to let you go right now.
We're not going to tell your parents,
but if you ever do this again,
we will call the police,
try to scare you.
Understand me.
And I was like,
Oh yeah,
I'm so sorry.
I can't believe we did it.
And then I told my friends,
they're like,
why'd you do it?
I'm like,
oh,
I don't even know.
I just wanted to see if I could do it.
I want a candy.
I didn't have any money.
Hey,
is this allowable?
And then you find out,
oh,
it's not.
I dated a girl in high school who's a
really bright girl.
Various,
yes.
Wow.
She's very smart and educated and you
know,
did really well for herself and you
wound up,
uh,
being an outstanding citizen.
But when she was in high school,
she had a problem like girls.
Well,
anybody,
you know,
you see things and you can't afford
them.
And when you're young,
you've never earned any money.
Yeah.
You also,
you have,
you still have these lapses and thinking
that are intensely juvenile,
especially if you grew up in a weird,
like single parent household like she
did or like,
you know,
a lot of people do,
or Latchkey kids where,
you know,
your parents just go get out of here and
they just let you out the door and you
figure out life on your own.
That's a lot of fucking kids.
And so I think she just got caught doing
it and it was devastating.
She was pretty honest about it.
Like how devastating it was.
Yeah.
She got caught with clothes,
you know,
she arrest security guard.
Yeah.
I guess what girls would do is we'll go
to a place and they would put clothes on
over their other clothes.
Go into the dressing room.
Yeah.
They'd go in the dressing room and like
hide stuff.
And this is like we're talking about,
I graduated in 1985 so I think is
probably like 83 or 84.
This is no computers.
Just know scanners on your items and you
walk out the door and RFID card goes
off.
You know,
those things that they have at this on
an rf ID.
What are those plastic things like?
It looks like a stapler clip onto your
shirt,
but if you don't take them off the
personal glue to try to take them home,
I don't think they had that shit back
then.
I think you just had to keep an eye on
people.
Do you remember when,
um,
there was a famous actress that got
caught?
Yeah,
that's right.
She got caught being a club.
That's one of the reasons I know that
any like scandal that falls a comic,
like it'll pass.
No one talks about going to a writer
being a shoplifter anymore.
We just did.
Well,
yeah,
but I mean,
people don't really pick up on that way.
Thank God when not respectable.
I remember at some point learning the
lesson was like,
Oh,
I'm an adult now.
If I got caught shoplifting,
now I'm just going to go to jail.
There's no like young man.
We'll talk to your parents.
I think people,
some people have just fucking lapses in
judgment and they do it because they're
like,
see,
I think subconsciously like someone,
like we're known a rider who's obviously
wealthy,
she's wealthy.
I think she's like Pr.
I mean,
I'm just totally playing armchair
psychologist here,
but I would say,
um,
it might seriously be that she's just
trying to charge up her day somehow.
Like subconscious,
the season,
the series premiere of our heroes,
the very first episode alert,
you're going to spoil her.
It again too.
That's fucking 12 years old,
bitch.
Anyway,
the fucking wife for the congressmen,
she gets caught shoplifting and people
go,
why don't you shop the,
she goes,
I just needed to feel something.
It was the worst writing ever heard.
She was after Frank Dodd.
I just needed to feel good.
Christ.
Yeah,
but,
uh,
did I steal from the airports all the
time?
You used to or do,
do,
what'd he steal?
I don't know.
If I buy a couple things that,
and they're super expensive.
The water is just coming with me for
free.
Whoa.
You shouldn't say this on the air.
What are they going to set up a sting
you at the airport?
Like we wanted those things.
It's just like,
or the banana.
I don't know.
Something.
Well,
why would you give a fuck you up?
Money.
Yeah,
because I just feel it's not justified
that they charged this much power with
that be oh,
Bernie Sanders all the way.
Every one.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean if I voted,
which I'm not,
but like I would do better if you vote
for sanders.
Um,
yeah,
it's not fair.
So stop it.
I go wait for 75 for the regular size
water and that does look like,
you know,
that's a lot,
right?
Yeah.
It's not my,
I don't,
you know,
it's fairly expensive.
However,
how much would I have to pay you to go
get some water,
purify it,
cool it off,
put it in a plastic jar and have it
sealed and waiting for me.
Hundred $50.
Yeah,
it's cost based on that.
Did I got into a fight with a guy on the
Great Wall of China?
He was selling cater rates and I had
just taken this long hike or,
I mean it was hot,
I was sweaty and I saw gatorade and I
was like,
yeah,
how much?
And he was like,
I forget how much it was.
Let's say he was like 20 you know un
right.
And I was like,
what do you mean the price is five bro,
you know,
the price is five and he goes 20 I'm
like,
I'm not a fucking tourist.
I've been here for two weeks already.
I already know the scam.
And he goes,
I walked it up from the fucking bottom
of the hill all the way up to the Great
Wall of China and I was like,
20 it is.
There you go.
Yeah,
man,
that's legit.
Yeah,
but it can't be stealing water
without the sup or if the line is too
long.
If the line is too long,
your own price.
I'm like,
I gotta go.
I was like,
ah,
Nah,
I'm just going to walk.
Sometimes I do that.
Sometimes you just take things.
Yeah.
Need pillows once in a while.
Really I,
I'm going to wait in the line.
I'm walking around looking for nuts.
I have a neck pillow.
It's on my suitcase now.
I put it on there.
I'm like,
no,
I'd probably just go,
this is not a good way to think.
Oh,
for sure.
This is a crime.
You're talking about steady crime,
whatever the what the American
government says I should do.
I don't agree with all that.
I don't think the government owns those
little stops at the airport.
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying what they say in terms of
stealing and not stealing.
I just don't listen to him laws.
Yeah.
Hmm.
But few corporations,
fuck them.
Steal what you want.
Apple,
what is a big corporation like?
Are those big corporations that have
those little stalls in them in the
airport?
I don't do it from the kiosks,
although I would do it from the Kia.
I just harder because you can't walk
around.
There's one guy looking,
but that doesn't make any sense.
Why are you doing that?
I don't know.
Good question.
Let me think about that.
This is something that could cause you a
giant problem if you've got yeah,
for sure.
I'd miss my flight.
Well,
not just miss your flight.
It would be a big deal.
I mean,
you could always plead it.
Not Anymore.
Not because of this.
Cause these evidence of this.
This is how much time I had a Koosh ball
at chesapeake knife and tool and I was
tossing around,
but I was looking at all the little
metal games.
You know those puzzle games,
you'd get the ring off and I was like,
oh I can easily take this right now.
And I just kept tossing it up and walked
right out of the store.
Cause if they caught me I'd be like,
Oh my God,
I'm so sorry.
Oh clearly I wasn't clearly.
I mean that was in high school.
You should go back and give it back to
them.
I want to go back to places I stole the
candy bar and pay for it.
Really?
No,
you've got to pay it for like five with
interests.
Oh my God.
You don't them found what kind of candy
bar?
I don't remember.
It's like a Hershey's bar or something.
Nothing exotic.
That's on you,
Tommy.
Yeah,
I've been a zero bar.
Maybe.
I don't remember.
10,000 grand I just made it was candy
fucking Hershey Bar.
What are you go fucking fried internment
camp guy from the fucking Japanese war.
Let me tell you something.
Chocolate Hershey's chocolate with
almonds still to this day is fucking
bang up.
This like charge America,
Hershey's chocolate and Jif peanut
butter.
This is what he's good.
That's good to break off the fucking
pieces of the Hershey's chocolate with
almonds and dig into a big Vat of Jif
peanut butter cup
or skippy.
You want to get crazy nutty ones.
I one they try to sell us that bullshit.
Where was a stripe of jelly and a stripe
peanut butter and a stripe.
Fuck you.
Unless you're eating with a spoon
straight out of the jar into your mouth.
It's like,
no,
I decide how much jelly and how much
peanut burgos goes on it.
This is stupid dude.
We were having a party for uh,
for,
this is not happening for my show.
Every Tuesday night,
12:30 AM class control,
three episodes left.
He has his company.
But anyway,
so we had s'mores.
We hit in the back of Eric and Sam's
place.
It was a little fire pit.
We had smores and rock.
I just burned him.
I just burned the mushroom,
not mushroom marshmallow and stick it on
there and smash and then skype Brian
Ball the,
and he's like,
dude,
I was a cub scout for 12 years.
It's not how you'd do it.
Oh,
let me show you.
And for the next 10 minutes,
he perfectly browned this marshmallow
from like eight feet above the fire,
like just made it so long.
And then he turns,
he goes,
see now this is,
I got a slap.
Don't have to the ground.
So
I was waiting for him to finish.
Uh,
he's the Franklins of
Oh my God.
That's hilarious dude.
You just shit on the Franklin Morris
People's heads.
I did it out of Gomez and he had an owl
towards tim that was open for so long.
I'm like,
why are you leaving?
You're making,
I don't want to do this to you.
You're forcing my hand.
And then you just slapped it up and he
goes to this please in in there.
The seller,
I know that we can look on the ground.
We found a lot of them.
It's so much fun to slap food out.
Someone said Josh Martin did that.
He was coming out of the back with a
fucking pretzel all cover with my
master's.
It's only great when they can easily
replace it.
Yes.
So you've got to get him five bucks.
Go deal with it.
If I ever got a lot of money,
I would smash people's I phones and just
stomp on them like,
here's $700 but then what if they're in
the middle of like a really important
conversation,
right?
Babysitter.
Yeah.
Now you get it.
Anyway,
Josh Martin comes out.
I just slapped that.
He goes,
oh,
and I could see he's looking at like,
maybe like,
anyway,
I'm like,
you're making me step on this man.
You're making me step on as you're
leaving me.
No choice.
Why comics so mean to each other.
It was so cool.
So mean to each other.
There was one of the funny stories,
stories I'll have to,
it was Louie and Norton.
Norton was talking about how he's
walking on the street with his slice of
pizza.
You just got it.
It was perfect,
was like,
it was such a juicy slight and Louie
walked over and smacked it,
ran out of his hand and says something
like,
your mother is a kind of
oh,
why is that so funny?
So funny.
It's like,
it's,
but it's only pain associated with no
real monetary loss.
It's not real.
You're like,
no.
That's why the cell phone doesn't work.
It's on.
It's real.
It's a real phone.
You'd have to give them like a grand.
Yeah.
It's not a slice of pizza that you just
easily replace.
Instead of the how comedians are cruel,
they are to each other.
He was like,
if you break up with a girl,
if you're the comedy store and you break
up with a girl,
you just don't tell anyone for like
eight months.
It's just they're not going to be cool
to you.
They're not going to say,
it's okay,
man.
They're just gonna be like,
who are you think's fucking her?
No.
Do you think she's fine?
Finally trying anal.
Oh,
that's true.
Yeah.
You just don't tell anybody until you're
over it and you're like,
okay,
now I can.
Okay.
Yeah.
That ended a year ago.
What?
What can we still make fun of you?
Yeah,
but it won't stick anymore.
Before it had two girlfriends since
then.
That's a lot of guys.
You've employed that strategy.
What?
Not telling anybody.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
I remember I'd be like,
where's,
what's her name?
Yeah.
It didn't work out.
I don't want to look at you.
Look one of your best friends a fucking
year,
Bro.
Got to keep that take
a year.
I was going to tell you,
I was going to tell you a bunch of Lee.
I Dunno man.
It'd been,
it has to be someone you like.
Like if someone that you didn't like as
a comedian came by and slapped your tic
tacs.
Oh yeah.
Then it's like,
who the fuck are you?
Exactly.
It only works if you really liked that
person.
Like I Rocco.
Yeah,
Rocco.
He's a nice guy,
but I didn't know him that well and I
yawned and he put his fucking two
fingers right in my mouth.
I'm like,
don't you don't fucking ever do that to
me again.
I was so mad.
But if you do it,
I'm like,
oh dude,
fucking gross.
That'd be the end of it.
But why would anybody do that?
I don't know.
I definitely don't want your hands with
my mouth and I didn't want my hands in
your mouth either.
What if someone's got some crazy gag
reflex?
Just chomps down.
That would be hilarious.
Sip.
You're like,
let me teach you.
I left it.
I may just barfs all over your are
bites.
You shoot it like a human bite is super
dangerous or like when,
yeah,
when Pete people have all sorts of funky
fucking bacteria in their mouth.
When a person bites you,
like if you get infected,
if you can get it cleaned up really
good,
really quick.
Yeah,
we're nasty.
It'll do shit to,
people get real sick.
They get real sick.
Well diseases that come from bites can
be particularly fucked up.
Like that's one of the things about
those Goddamn Komodo dragons.
I'm pretty sure checking C in this cause
I might be mistaken,
but I'm pretty sure they used to think
that they have venom.
They used to think they produce a venom
and now they,
or it might be the other way around that
they used to think that it was just
bacteria in their mouth that killed just
fucking slime.
Their mouth develops a slime.
The really weird,
the Komodo dragons there,
their mouth is like,
like someone just blew snot in their
mouth.
Like they open their mouth up and it's
like,
like you,
if you just sneeze,
if you had the flu and fucking goos
coming out of your mouth,
one,
two punch.
They have sharp teeth and a venomous
bite.
Okay.
Dispels the common belief that toxic
bacteria in the commodos mouse are
responsible.
So that's the old belief.
So she wins her worse than Komodo
dragons.
Yeah.
Well,
if it probably kill you eventually,
if they bit you,
I'm sure this fucking nasty shit in
their mouth,
but the venom,
they actually have a venom,
but for the longest time they thought
that it was just bacteria.
Because like show a picture of a Komodo
dragon with its mouth open.
It's fucking vile,
man.
I want to see one of those Komodo
island.
It's only one place where they looked
at.
Yeah.
Wow.
They don't have them in zoos and you
sure what do they definitely do,
but I mean one place where they exist in
the wild.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure.
Pretty sure.
It's only one area.
Like look at his mouth.
That slime.
Yeah.
The whole thing is just slimes Ville and
apparently that shit's all toxic.
Oh,
pass those pretty fast right there.
They'll come at you.
They're fucking big man.
These things eat water buffaloes and
shit.
No Way.
Yeah.
They bite him and then they follow him
for days until they die and then date
them.
They are the creepiest of the creeps.
Got fucking bulldog.
They're so disgusting.
I mean,
they're beautiful in a lot of ways.
there,
there's a spectacular example source.
Oh yeah.
I mean they are dinosaurs,
man.
Look at that one right there that you
just passed over.
Jamie said.
Yeah,
look at that fucking thing.
Go full screen on that.
What?
In the law?
Sharp claws.
And it's built like a pit bull.
It's got giant muscles everywhere
almost.
They're so gross.
Or let me see it.
Eating a waterproof.
I want to see how big it is and scale.
Well,
what they do is they ran up to a,
there's a video of,
um,
a Kimono dragon running up to this water
buffalo and biting its leg and then it
follows it for days.
Look at that one.
It's often dolphin,
a beach dolphin.
A beach stouffer.
Yeah.
Probably died.
And they're eating it after it died.
Oh,
so much.
That happens a lot with bears.
It's like there's a cow that ones
because they're eating the head off FAA.
Yeah.
Their moms are pretty big.
Okay.
They're pretty big.
Oh yeah.
There are hundreds of pounds there.
The biggest lizards in the world.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't know how,
I mean,
I think they probably get to like 800
pounds or something like that.
Like find out how big they are.
And Jamie has a Komodo dragon fight.
Well that's what happened to Sharon
stone's husband.
What?
Sharon stone's husband is this like
swash buckling journalism type
character.
He does like a lot of crazy stuff and
uh,
yeah.
Or I guess she's not married to him.
I knew I,
what do I got?
Some magazine.
Okay.
But,
but this guy who was like his real macho
guy and a deal,
a lot of macho type shit.
And one of the things they did was he
got into some,
a cage with a Komodo Dragon.
Then they took,
he took his shoes off for whatever
reason.
Like,
maybe take your shoes off so that you
don't step in their habitat with,
you know what might possibly be on your
shoes cage with him.
Yeah.
And the fucking thing bid his foot
because he thought it thought his foot
was a rabbit cause its foot was white
and they feed them rabbits.
Jesus fucking Christ.
So this thing,
imagine that.
Think clamping down on your foot with
that slime mouth.
He almost lost his foot.
Really?
Yeah,
they go.
Okay.
They're a lot smarter than I thought to
melt one 70 to 200 pounds.
I thought there were like eight or 900
pounds reaching 10 feet.
10 feet in length.
Jesus.
200 pounds.
300 pounds.
But animals.
Huh?
Reaching 10 feet and more than 300
pounds says this.
This is National Geographic to huh.
Maybe that's as big as it can get you.
It's not like to get him on a scale.
Right.
Food with 30 pounds.
Okay.
What does a lot of,
either way,
they're big nonfat it's more research to
be done.
What's Kinda interesting is they're the
biggest lizards.
Yeah.
So I guess a crocodile is not a lizard.
I bet the way bigger crocodiles are way
bigger crocodiles.
Not a lizard.
No,
I guess it's not.
Cause if that's the biggest lizard,
maybe there's a separate genus.
Is Crocodile Lizard Janice or genius.
Genius.
Genius for um,
for alligators and crocodiles,
they might be their own thing.
Oh maybe I'm not lizards.
Well there's so much bigger than that.
The Komodo dragon cannot be the biggest
lizard.
Cause crocodiles like Niall crocs are
fucking giant.
How big are those?
They're huge.
The biggest ones,
I think they've ever recorded like 28
feet long.
Well pretty sure it cocktails for sure.
Lizard.
Yeah,
it seems like it would be right.
But then how are they saying that the
Komodo dragons,
the largest lizard in the world?
I don't know that it is it when I typed
it in,
something like that.
I see it's like largest species found on
the Indonesian islands.
Oh that's not like there's a couple.
Yeah,
I swear I read that.
That's the largest lizard in the world.
Maybe it was.
Maybe they meant the largest monitor,
monitor,
Lizard Family Var and I,
it is largest living species of lizard.
Okay,
so it was the largest species of
lizards.
Yeah.
So what does that mean?
The largest species monitor.
Oh,
the largest
volume.
Okay,
okay.
That makes sense.
But what the fuck's crocodile?
Is it a lizard?
But I've made,
they have other stuff in the species.
Yeah,
it's smaller,
right?
Well there's a gang of different
monitors is what it is.
Right.
Did you ever see a crocodile monitor?
Their fucking bad ass know how to
monitor?
Does that mean monitor?
It's a type of Lizard,
but a crocodile monitor is like these
really cryptic looking creepy fucking,
I think Eddie Bravo knew a girl had one
as a pet.
I'd one.
Yeah,
like one of those crazy goth chicks like
snakes.
You know what?
I don't like dogs.
So I'll get a lizard crocodile Mont.
You like dogs.
Why would you get a fucking crowd?
You're in character.
Got The eyeballs and that thing looks
like it's animated.
That doesn't even look like a real
eyeball.
Right.
It looks like a dinosaur for sure.
Yeah.
I'll take it.
Everyone.
Andy Circus was a giant name because he
did that play by play for a Gollum.
No,
put things on him.
I Dunno who that is.
What are you talking call up in the
hobby and the hobbit movies really knew
who he was.
Yeah.
Then he did like a,
just a bunch of stuff like that.
When they put those things all over you
and they had to like act like,
oh,
well he's a very good physical actor.
If that was his body and that he was
moving around like that.
He was a great gollum like,
and what they did with him.
Just good though.
He was really solid.
It was me.
That was great.
No,
that was a,
that was a great part of that.
Did you read the Hobbit?
Did you ever do?
Yeah,
I mean,
I think he was as good as you could've
been.
Yeah.
No.
Yeah,
totally believable.
We're that CGI.
Even though you kind of know you're
watching a cartoon,
you know,
you kind of get it.
But he also aged unnaturally for a
thousand years,
so it's not like he's supposed to be a
regular.
Right,
right.
You know thing the hobbit was such dog
shit.
How dare you.
The Lord of the rings is amazing.
How dare you on all accounts.
You thought the Lord of the rings was
not as good as the hobbit?
No,
no.
I don't remember which ones were which
names,
but I liked all of them.
Oh,
really?
Didn't like all of them equally,
but they're were all good enough and one
of them was like to set up some other
shit.
Like sometimes they do a lot of that.
Lord of the rings was three and those
were all great.
Yeah,
the Hobbit,
they turned into three.
I don't know why.
I mean,
I know why the smile,
desolation of smile.
You didn't like the punch a talk at
like,
we need to join this battle.
I don't want to go to the bat.
We need you.
Alright.
And I fucking 20 minutes of that,
Jamie.
You know,
I'm right on that.
I didn't watch any of those works.
They didn't freak you out in the fucking
Lord,
Lord of the rings.
They didn't freak you out in the most
recent one.
No,
they seem like Fango plus they were kind
of easy to kill this time.
It's super easy to kill when fucking
bill kill it or cause I'm like,
wait,
how would at 1.0 they,
these fucking evil super villains that
are created in a lab and then the next
point,
the fucking little hobbit with no
training can get them.
Oh,
that's a good point.
That was one scene when they're in the
barrels going down the river,
spoiler alert and I'm like,
he can't just kill everybody.
You can't,
you know,
in the barrels,
you guys aren't losing anybody.
Nobody,
you know,
lose anybody.
Not No casualties.
ORCS with bows and arrows jumping off a
fucking cliff is falling apart with the
two mountains were fighting and they're
jumping from thing to thing.
All fine.
Everybody's fine.
It can be done in a way that would make
you think that although there's magic in
this world that they live in,
the physics of the regular world still
apply.
You got to shoot it,
right?
Yeah.
That seat,
the problem is in these movies,
it's not just the magic that you have to
concede.
You have to concede that that's the
world they set up.
It's okay.
Yeah,
you set up this world,
it's fine.
Right.
Spiderman can shoot things cause they
said at the world,
but he can't fly,
but the physics of their movements,
like what happens,
how they battle these orcs.
Yeah.
Gravity supposed to be normal.
It doesn't make any sense and you can't
just constantly almost die and keep
going.
It's like how to build,
we'll get away.
Well,
he's got a ring.
It touches me invisible.
Okay,
that works,
but you can't just like fucking fuck it
holes and when people almost die and
then almost dying and almost dying
almost island,
you burn out my almost die nerve.
I don't care.
I don't,
I don't believe you are in danger.
Yeah.
That happens in movies sometimes.
It's just a bunch of shit happening.
I have this theory that most artists
have about a seven.
I'm tweaking the years but about how its
seven year prime where they're really on
point and Peter Jackson is that who did
the Lord of the rings in the habit?
Yeah.
Like he was,
that was amazing.
And then King Kong came and you're like
oh maybe.
And then the hobbit.
It's a Dario.
You don't really,
how dare you karody anymore.
King Kong was awesome.
So socket,
same thing.
They'll brontosaurs are going all around
them.
Fucking stopping right next to him.
Like Google.
That was a close one.
Yeah.
Well I felt like it weighed about
Jurassic Park,
the new Jurassic Park and watch.
And I was like okay here it comes.
More stuff happening and bunch of
stuff's gonna happen now and this is
going to happen and it's just a bunch of
shit that like I have zero connection
to.
It's undeniably visually impressive.
It's amazing.
Special effects.
I have zero emotions.
It's all part of it.
You've got to draw me in and the people
will go like,
well why?
He said,
that's why I did it because of this and
like,
ah,
whatever saying it's not showing it.
I hate to bring this movie you again,
but I,
I bring it up a lot.
Uh,
x Makena oh yeah.
I just watched it.
I just saw her a few example.
Just saw it like there's just amount of
Shit,
enough amount of shit happening.
Like spectacular spellbound,
spellbound,
spellbinding instead of word
spellbinding
cliffhanging like you're fucking
nervous.
What's going to happen?
Massive anticipation.
There's all sorts of different elements
at play.
You've got artificial intelligence.
It's perhaps plotting against you and
there's so much going on,
man.
And there's scenes in that movie.
Were you like,
fuck,
fuck.
Like you're white knuckling.
I didn't feel any of that in lecture
rassic part.
Oh,
right,
right.
I just didn't feel it.
I was like,
they're going to be fine.
They're going to be coming up with an ex
mackinaw where it's like,
do a better job.
It really like what the weight falls in
love in a week.
It's like,
Eh,
make it a month to you.
And I know guys who fall in love in an
hour.
Yeah.
Come on man.
A robot that hot.
You don't think Duncan would go under
quick?
Jonathan would be gone by the end of the
first.
Hey Dude,
it's a new form of life duty.
She's,
I love her man.
I love her.
I'll come on dude.
Once she's got the skin on and the skin
is indistinguishable from your,
your skin,
you're not going to give a fuck about
that carbon fiber body that looks like
the inside of one of those.
I mean it was just like,
it was one of those things where mostly
it was like,
it was like he wasn't love at all.
He's like,
you're a robot euro,
but then all of a sudden it's like,
I'm a failure in love with you.
I didn't see the,
the,
the change in him.
I saw it coming.
I saw it the moment I saw that guy sit
down with her.
I saw coming too.
So I have to see it happen.
I can't just be like,
oh,
you know,
so obviously falls in love.
Well obviously he gets access to all my
computers.
How does it work with people?
What,
how does it work with people,
with people you never know.
Like people get when people,
when some people get,
we all have friends that have gone in
these relationships where they just go
away,
they're gone.
I know,
but he liked me like three times and
then it was like,
Nah,
I'm willing to.
Yeah,
but it doesn't matter man.
If he decided at some point in time that
this is like a form of life and that he
really has a real connection with her,
she really is intelligent.
I mean he keep getting feedback from her
over and over again,
but I'm saying show that you don't think
they showed that that was,
it was,
it was a leap.
I still really enjoyed the movie.
It's still really,
really enjoyed it.
But no,
they didn't really show it.
It just kind of,
hmm.
They were like,
Eh,
you know,
maybe you got a point.
Like maybe they could have added a bit
more to that because of you draw me in
emotionally.
If I feel the falling in love right,
then I'm going to guess you should be
free.
See,
I just saw it from like a predatory
point of view.
I go,
here's a wounding,
wounded antelope.
Here's a waterhole,
here's a crocodile.
How much it's going to get them.
She's going to get go.
She's hot as fuck.
He's a super dork who's never around
women.
Yeah.
I don't care if she's a robot.
That dude was so great too at the bail.
He was great.
Everybody was great.
All three of them were great.
The goal was amazing.
She's amazing because she played.
It's so good,
man.
It was spooky.
I'm also,
I'm just going to say,
I don't know if it's,
her choices are the way they directed or
wrote it,
but we should a good God damn.
She nailed it.
She,
she seemed like a fucking robot man.
And then,
spoiler,
spoiler alert,
the Asian robot that you've kind of
thought was a robot but weren't sure,
and then you find out she's a robot.
It was for sure,
you know,
by or robot because the way they show
her,
like the hip conversations with her in
the foreground of the people in the
background while you're showing this
servant presold long,
but when you first saw her,
she was just some freaky servant that he
had and then the more they showed her,
the more he realized either she is a
spa,
trying to get stuff was,
but she's definitely not in the level.
Yeah,
I definitely figured it out once they
started making out once they were,
when who's having disco parties about
what?
At that point I was like,
oh,
he bangs robots and why wasn't it?
Yeah.
Well,
it's just a flat slight,
but isn't that the thing was amazing.
That was amazing.
Yeah.
I want to talk to you about the power of
cutting up.
Let's first talk about cutting it up on
this dance floor.
Yeah.
What was such a good movie,
man?
There's so many elements of it that took
you by surprise theory that we all want
freedom.
I will do whatever we can to get
Right.
You know,
just the themes behind it,
including that.
I mean that's kind of interesting cause
that's what killed all his other eyes.
That they want it out.
Yeah.
They need to see the outside world.
They'll do anything they can to,
to lay off the fucking chains of
oppression on you.
I want out,
well,
if you're trying to create a life,
right,
you're going to credit create an
artificial life.
You want to give that life all of the
elements,
the basic elements that motivate us.
Like otherwise it won't be a person.
It'll just be flat and scary.
Yeah.
Like if they don't have an insecurity,
they don't have love.
They don't have warmth,
they don't have humor,
they don't have curiosity.
They have all of it.
So if they have curiosity,
they're going to want to go,
you want to go see?
You can't hear the person I've ever
seen.
That's what she sees.
I was like,
hmm.
Interesting.
And then that can understand you wanting
to control them.
Either.
They're going to be like,
why?
Why can't you just let me go?
I just got out.
Can I just leave?
Please let me leave.
Yeah,
no,
you're not ready.
What do you mean the ones who would
destroy themselves?
Banging on the walls.
He's only two years old.
Yeah,
but I'm like 50 to give me a 50 year
old.
I didn't program her flirt with you.
It's just happening.
Have you seen the movie,
the room,
that terrible,
terrible,
terrible movie.
Which one?
The new one that was just in the Oscars
this past year.
That's not that.
You don't know about the room.
I feel like I know what you guys are
talking about something,
one of the worst movies ever made.
It's not just one of the worst movies
ever made.
It's perplexing.
Like you,
you watching,
you go,
okay,
this is not real.
This is that.
It's not a real move.
It's maybe an open micah,
but like a crazy open miker,
you know,
great way to describe it.
You know?
And then he's like,
I got some money to make a movie.
There was a billboard for that movie on,
on libray sunset.
It was it.
Oh yeah,
Lebron such that,
that,
that's the,
uh,
get your own billboard.
He's always had these rappers.
Do you ever heard of like,
yeah.
See,
see about two balls?
Well,
I was looking at a piece of property,
um,
that uh,
one of the things that they were talking
about,
the piece of property that's adjacent to
a has this like billboard thing there
and you could pay and put things on the
billboard.
I'm like,
how much did it cost to put something on
a bill?
How much it's not that much man.
It's like a couple thousand bucks a
month.
Couple thousand bucks a month.
Yeah.
To put something on and I'll be worth it
for a good prank.
Yeah.
Fuck nick food.
It's a lot of that up there.
I mean it a lot depending upon where
you're at and how big the billboard is.
But I'm like,
um,
I know a guy owns billboards,
he's got a few of them.
It depends on where it is.
That one of the break,
I know what you're talking about.
Yeah.
That is a cheaper one because there's
always up stuff is up there.
Like this isn't even a professional,
this isn't an Aldo,
this isn't anything.
This is just like,
yeah.
And that guy had that movie poster up
there for all long time and he made it
all himself.
And in every scene he had to make out
with chicks people.
Yeah you to make it.
What tricks and the sexiness of the love
scenes would last so long.
They were like five and a half minutes
and it doesn't make any sense.
It's,
it's just showing his body's showing his
ass.
He's a handsome guy.
That's it.
Oh no,
that's not that one.
That's a different thing.
He probably had a bunch of them cause
that's down by,
where's that one?
That's further down.
I know where Hollywood boulevard.
Yeah
maybe.
No it's facing,
is that the back of the room?
Whatever.
Anyway,
it's prime time allocation.
Yeah,
for sure.
And that guy had that billboard up there
fucking forever.
It's a crazy movie.
People get together and watch it.
Like just to go,
what in the fuck.
If you have money you can just make shit
happen.
They don't have,
they don't say that this isn't good
enough.
There's nobody stopping you.
You're an adult like sure.
Spend it.
That's why trump's gonna be president.
Cause what?
Cause he's got money.
Nobody's got,
nobody could stop him and tell him he
can't do it.
I have to answer.
It's the same thing,
but it wasn't so crazy.
I like the idea that he's like,
I'm not taking money from anybody.
I'll make my own decisions.
But then you're like,
oh,
but your decisions are naughty.
But you know what that problem is?
That's like,
I like strippers,
do coke,
but I want them to be good moms.
Right,
right,
right.
That'd be,
if that was your exact tire,
that'd be tough fired.
Cause you don't,
you don't get a guy who is that fucking
like braggadocious bold Americana.
Wiki American America.
Great.
Again,
golf hat on private jet.
Suck my Dick.
[inaudible] how about you suck my Dick.
You don't can't guy unless you get also
like the nasty tweets to Megan Kelly.
You know,
and the,
you know,
this,
this reporters,
I'll lose her and this guy a stucco
scratch dude,
I don't really like to Bates.
It's all a bunch of lies and half
truths.
Like,
well,
he voted for,
uh,
making slavery legal again and the,
but now I did.
And you know,
God damn well and said,
why do you say shit like that?
So it just makes me mad.
I'm not getting the truth and lie all
the time.
But these Republican debates are so fun.
These guys are really trying to say what
they want to say,
jump sorry
with my hair.
So eat.
And they're like,
what?
What does that happen?
They're failing.
They don't understand the deal with
this.
Well,
he's,
Alexander came in and people are like,
how can you fight this?
And you're like,
you'll figure out a way,
but you didn't get it yet.
Yeah,
right.
He's just a way better talker than that
in terms of like,
they're getting the reaction out of
people and he's also figured out a way
to manipulate the media.
Some of you,
how about yourself?
What's your view on this?
How about you shut up.
He's a very smart guy.
It despite like all the criticisms that
you could have that are all valid about
the wall and about some of the things
that he said.
He's very smart and honestly what the
media says,
they only show you a small portion of
something.
So at this point,
I don't trust them.
When did these crazy like quotes?
You're like,
he said that what?
And you're like,
no,
he didn't exactly say that per easy to
shit on.
Right.
But that's the point is that he knows
that that's going to get him all this
attention.
He gets way more media attention than
anybody else combined press is bad
press.
Look,
everybody knows that Hillary Clinton was
the secretary of state.
Everybody knows she's running for
president.
But do you,
if you compare the amount of time the
pundits talk about Hillary Clinton
versus the amount of time they talk
about trump,
it's not even close and it's all because
of hib saying outrageous shit.
It's like,
talk about him.
Yes,
and he sells more.
He's a genius in that respect.
I think he knows that too.
He fucking for sure knows it.
He's like 60 years old,
man,
he's a billionaire or you're a smart
dude.
Fucked.
Yeah.
He goes,
he doesn't know she's,
he made $7 billion.
I think he's a bit crafty from scratch,
from scratch.
I think he knows that she wants him for
his money.
Doesn't give a fuck.
He's got eight years left on this world.
He doesn't need all that money.
If if,
yeah.
Yeah.
I think that this guy,
what you're seeing from him from
trump's,
yeah,
it's his best way to win the show and
he's winning.
Like he would win celebrity apprentice
if he was one of the guests.
He's winning by making everybody else
fight his fight.
Turn into an insult.
Match these Ted Cruz guys.
Do you think he really wants to be
insulting trump?
Think Mitt Romney.
Mitt Romney goes in and he's,
he's not even a fucking running for
president,
and he goes,
I'm this Republican campaign like trump
by anti trump rant.
It's what all these soft celebrities
there,
there's park made fun of in a,
in a team America,
there's all these celebrities go on and
say we're against the war were or
whatever we're against,
you know,
that's,
it still gets Bush
and that just made people vote for Bush.
All failed.
He didn't do anything.
It doesn't work.
That's like George Clooney is not going
to change your vote.
Yeah.
Especially when he's trying to change
your vote.
They don't just happen to ask him in
passing.
It's like,
it's like I can see you stumping.
It's like those,
the more you know,
commercials on NBC.
Remember these,
do those spend some time with your kids.
The more you know.
Yeah.
Kids that spend time with their parents
are less likely to kill themselves.
The more you know Conan into the great
one about that.
Teddy,
he just,
it was a whole series of like,
was his after he left NBC or what?
While he was on?
I think it was on
late night,
but it's kind of the same thing.
You know?
It's like,
shut the fuck up.
You're not,
you're not fixing anything.
Yeah.
I just wonder if who he really is.
This is the real,
yeah.
This is my real problem with drought.
People Defend Hillary Clinton's smart,
intelligent,
liberal people.
I know.
I go,
but she seems like she's standing go.
She's smart because she was saying what
she needs to get elected.
I'm like,
well,
okay,
well then how is that different than
Donald Trump?
If you don't believe she's believes
these things,
she's just doing what she has to to get
elected.
Then how can you not believe the same
about Donald Trump?
Her speeches creeped me out way more
than his,
and I'll tell you why.
She got called out by Bernie Sanders for
having these enormous fucking campaign
speech,
not campaign speeches with speeches that
she would give in front of these bankers
where they would pay or hundreds of
thousands of dollars.
And Bernie Sanders was like,
let's see the transcripts.
I want to know how amazing this speech
must have been that it's worth $250,000
zero so she won't show the trends of the
switches and scripts.
Why?
Cause she's got some shit in those
transcripts.
I'm sure that makes her look bad.
And so she's actively hiding it and she
goes,
oh,
just not release it.
Exactly.
But think what else the cheesiest.
Yeah,
I mean think about what else,
who you are,
we're going to vote for you.
It tells who you are.
She can't,
not in this.
I mean it had to be understood from the
jump that she was going to give these
speeches and they're not going to get
out because they must be in favor at
least somewhat to the bankers.
Could you imagine?
It could be a fly on the wall and watch
a $250,000 speech by the wife of a
former former president who,
what the fuck are we paying for?
Let's say $250,000 it reeks up.
You don't have,
they can't scalp tickets,
so they go,
here's his Boston red sox hat because
forgeard bucks and you get a free ticket
to the world series game with it.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
It's like a loophole.
It's a bribe and it's like,
all right,
so she's just,
she's not going to turn on the people
who give her all this cash.
Dude,
I worked the door at the comedy store
and if you gave me 10 bucks for a booth,
I will be your slave for the night.
I'm not going to tell you that,
but anything that needs like,
hey,
is there a way?
I'll get it right now.
Excuse me.
And I'll just run and get away.
I was like,
yeah,
250 grand.
You know,
it's tricky,
dude.
You're going to do what's best for the
American public if it's close.
It's tricky cause that's bribery.
I mean that's just straight bribery.
It's just bribery without a contract.
He,
he's any,
he's like,
and you're going to just talk.
Yeah.
And if and if,
if she's really hiding what you said,
cause not hiding that she did the
anymore that's
out where everybody knew the speeches
were taking place.
So if she's one of the main reasons why
they become president in the first
place,
there's insanely lucrative,
right?
Bill Platelets.
Yeah.
They've made over $190 million Bill
Clinton speeches from dumb doing
speeches between him and her.
Wow.
So this is an insane business.
It becomes an insane business.
Like a Bernie is like,
show me those transcripts.
If you want to know my tries it,
guess what?
I would never even talk to them.
I wouldn't take a dollar from them.
He's like,
I'll give her nephew.
They don't exist.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I don't,
I've never talked to them.
I wouldn't talk to them while he's got
excellent points.
And that was fucking glossed over in the
news.
Glossed over on Fox News,
glossed over and here.
And if there's ever any place where you
know for sure that the government has an
influence on the media,
it's with access.
This is what it is folks.
It's not that the government pays the
media and gets them to not talk about
certain things cause that's slippery.
That could get out.
And if that got out there fucked,
but what if it got out that the
government was actively paying the,
uh,
CNN to not talk about Hillary Clinton's
speeches to the bankers?
Like,
look,
here's the directive.
You are not to talk.
That's bad.
That could be super bad because that's
an important campaign point when it
comes.
The thing is if she waits long enough,
if,
let's just say she starts winning more
states and she's like,
you know,
put some distance,
I'll go to her and Ben,
Bernie,
and then it comes out well too late,
right?
Because it didn't cost me these 31
states.
So now for the last 19 okay.
Yeah,
it'll cost me a little bit.
It's too late.
So,
but it's almost like,
yeah man,
we're voting,
let's give us the information.
But that would cost the Democratic Party
of the ticket if,
if,
if it got out that she did that,
like at the end,
if they got the transcripts and they
were really devastating,
even if she already got the nomination,
it would cost the Democratic Party of
the ticket to trump.
Oh,
100% on what it is.
Because trump has also like a Wall
Street type guy.
Yeah.
But it doesn't matter if anyone's on the
fence,
if there's,
because trump paid her to come to his
wedding.
She was at his wedding.
Really?
Yeah.
He paid her like hundreds of thousands
of dollars.
That's what he would do.
Here's the deal.
Okay.
I don't,
I don't want to say I bet I can.
I've turned down money.
I've turned down more money than I could
afford to turn down because I don't
believe in the thing that they're paying
me.
Well,
see,
but I'm a degenerate.
I'm not to be respected.
She's running for President United
States of America.
She's running for a position that's
supposed to have all of our respect you.
If you don't,
if you hate a Donald Trump type,
why would you go to his wedding?
Well,
see,
she didn't hate Donald Trump before he
was running for president saying those
things.
I think what his perspective is is he
knows this system as good as anybody
does because he's been paying these
motherfuckers before he became one of
those.
He was bribing them to come to his
wedding and shit.
Like what's his name?
From back to school?
Yeah.
Uh,
what's that guy's name?
Rodney dangerfield day.
Just feels like I got to pay this guy a
pit.
That was his business class.
No,
no,
no.
You've got to pay the city planner.
You got to go.
You got to grease up palms by people.
Shit.
And Donald Trump's known that forever.
He's,
he's,
there's two things he's got going for
them in a big way.
One,
you can't fucking by him.
He's got plenty.
Owe money.
You can't buy him.
Hammer Bernie.
Yeah.
And no matter how much you say he's got
somebody,
they'll say he has 10 billion.
Some people it's,
if he's got 10 billion for sure can't
buy it.
You could suck his dick.
It's over.
He doesn't give a fuck.
That guy is famous and rich as fuck and
his wife is hot and he's wins,
wins there all of his name on them all
over the world.
He fucking wins,
right?
So there's that.
He's got that going for him.
So he doesn't need their influence.
Right.
And then two on top of it,
he understands how to manipulate the
media better than all of them.
He knows how to say crazy shit.
He knows.
He knows how to get people to talk about
him.
And he represents something unique.
He represents like this character,
this,
this like guy who talks about a biggest
dick.
Is he like there's someone said
something about his hands,
Ted Cruz said something about it.
He goes,
uh,
you know,
I,
I don't know what he's implying,
but I,
I'm sure you have no problem down there
either,
but he's telling you he's got a big
Dick.
I mean black and
white dudes across the world fucking
through their beer,
up in the air,
jumped out of the couch.
Finally we got one of ours.
It's like there's a lot of weird shit
going on right now in the world.
And I think a trump presidency is a nice
cold,
wet slap in the face.
Like,
wake the fuck up.
Slap.
We all have to participate.
Here's who I want to win Bernie first
than Donald Trump and then whatever.
Then I don't care anymore because here's
why Donald Trump,
if he buries a system,
I'm like,
fuck it.
Let's take it all away.
Let's show how little the fucking
president can actually do.
Yeah,
let's show it.
Little effect.
It actually has.
It's all just going to be shitty.
Well,
he'll tell us.
That's going to be weird.
He'll tell us what it's like to area 51.
Here's the oral shit.
Those ladies on the view are losers
president to tell you,
stop watching that piece of garbage show
that is more fun than when they go.
With all due respect to Secretary
Clinton.
Um,
uh,
you're a great job,
well respected.
Uh,
but I would like to say it's just like,
fuck you.
He keeps talking shit about that Megan
Kelly woman.
And that's a bad idea.
Kelly.
Megan Kelly,
she's a an anchorwoman for Fox News.
She's one of those ice,
you talk shit about Donald Trump.
Donald Trump and her hate each other.
Well she doesn't hate him,
but he's said a lot of bad thoughts
about her as a reporter.
How about her being second rate?
She asked him mean questions.
She or he felt,
he felt he didn't like her line of
questioning when they were doing
debates.
Apparently she's just,
she's an ice queen,
you know,
she's like the really hot,
really smart blonde lady on Fox News.
Like you could say,
you could say about her that she's
really hot.
Oh,
she's a hot lady on TV.
You can't say she's not smart.
She's wicked smart.
She's very smart.
She's like,
um,
but with all due respect,
she's like a milfy blonde lady.
But I'm telling you,
man,
to go for that,
she's fucking whip smart.
Like when she's taught,
like she doesn't take any bullshit and
so they went back and forth.
So,
but the problem is he's going after her
like he says that she's second raid and
he's a attacking her.
The problem is she's not well,
is he trying to,
it looks bad,
but the Po is,
he just trying to get her off so that
she can't,
so he discredits her blood here.
Scroll down.
Right criticism of him here.
It was like,
no,
he can't do that.
Isn't it terrible that Megan Kelly used
a pole not used before ibd when I was
down,
but refuses to use it now when I am up,
he's like,
there was a bunch of these things where
he was tweeting at her directly and he'd
go,
the problem,
the problem is me,
she's not perfect.
She was another one that was like,
Santa Claus is white.
Remember that she was a bitch.
Sorry,
I'll do respect.
Santa Claus isn't real.
He could be a rabbit.
Let's make,
let's switch places with the Easter
Bunny Easter bunnies.
Now an old man who shows up with him on,
is he just trying to get it like,
I don't want her on my debates anymore.
Well,
there was a black Santa,
you can say like you're involved in the,
uh,
in the story now.
Like if I had a judge who knew me,
yeah.
You know,
I'd be like,
ah,
you got to recuse this judge because I
had sex with his daughter.
Yeah.
But either way it's weak.
It's not,
it's not the way to do it like he was,
he's trying to do is as shame her and
attacker and she's not responding and
turn,
she's reporting on shit that's happening
and she's not being flattering about
him.
Right.
But she's not attacking him the way he's
attacking her.
And that looks real bad,
man.
Especially when it's a woman.
So when you're going after her and she's
smart,
look whether or not you agree with her,
whether or not you agree with their
politics.
There's no denying that.
She's very intelligent,
very articulate.
So when she's talking and she's giving
these speeches,
even if you think that this white Santa
Claus thing is nonsense and why,
why are you correcting America and what
color Santa Claus is the fuck you like
when when she's asking questions and
she's got these criticisms,
if you feel the criticisms aren't valid,
you have to be able to establish that.
You can communicate really well with
someone who doesn't think your
criticism.
That was someone who doesn't think that
you're doing a good job or someone is
criticizing you.
You have to establish if you're running
for president,
you have to establish that you are the
type of person is reasonable.
Oh,
he's not going to,
he's,
he's already said,
he's like,
if you cross me,
I will cross your back.
I will shut you down.
That's great if you're the fucking host
of celebrity apprentice,
but once you become a president,
I need a free media can help people
worried about criticizing you.
Yes.
Turkey.
Yeah.
You can't have people worried about
criticizing you when it comes to
something as critical as being a calm,
cool,
collected person who's running for
president.
Like that is the,
that is one of the most important points
of that job is that you have to be able
to appreciate the fact that there's
going to be at least half the country.
That fucking is mad that you're an
office.
Yeah.
Sometimes more.
I mean it gets insane.
So then she was Santa Claus tension mean
that just Saint Nicholas was white.
Oh,
and he's not really either.
Waze,
Saint Nicholas is her real,
but she was just talking about a black
Santa,
I forget.
There was some story where people said,
well know why can't we have a black sand
or something.
I don't remember what it was,
but she was like,
first of all,
sand is white.
Let's see if we could pull up the video
where she says Sam was white cause she's
so hot.
It's like it's kind of hot when she says
it.
Even know it was kind of ignorant.
Caution not be a white man anymore.
And when I saw this headline,
I kind of laughed.
I said,
no,
this isn't,
it's so ridiculous.
Yet another person claiming it's racist
to have a white Santa,
you know,
and by the way,
for all your kids watching at home,
Santa just is white.
But this person has just arguing then
that maybe we should,
we should also have a black Santa
Button.
You know,
Santa is woody is and just so you know,
we're just debating this because got the
brakes.
Okay.
Wanting to get that straight,
but jedediah
she's fucking talking to little kids out
there.
She's like,
she's in on the lie to little kids.
That's what she's doing.
By the way,
kids,
if you listening out there,
Santa is real and he's white.
What are the fucking news program?
The Jew and the right in the middle of a
controversial story to let all the kids
listening at home?
No,
the Santa Claus White.
Just pick picture in these kids with
fucking wonder.
Bread sandwiches half hanging out of the
mouth and processing meat.
The mouths wide open
for all you kids out there and they
paused the fucking food crumbs falling
onto the shag carpet that hasn't been
vacuumed than a month that smells like
cat piss
Santa Claus is why
I got to Piss.
Can you go ahead fellow?
I've,
I'd be like eight times.
And you pissed once yesterday.
Let's,
I've got a strong bladder son.
It's been established.
So my point young Jamie,
while the ours left us,
he doesn't care about politics.
She says ridiculous shit but he makes it
out that,
I don't know man.
I think when someone's criticizing you
and you're running for president,
what do you should be able to do is show
that that criticism is ridiculous.
What he does is he decides he's going to
go after those reporters but maybe
thinks that those reporters have a bully
pulpit.
You know,
that they abuse it cause there's some of
them that do crossover until line of
editorial commentary and it really kind
of twisted way.
But I didn't,
I didn't hear that she did that.
I think what she did is have like valid
criticisms.
You just said that.
What's stopping any of these,
uh,
candidates from having their own
podcasts daily.
Weekly.
Nothing question.
That's a good question.
It can be saying they could interview
whoever they want.
Like,
you know,
Bernie could offer to have hillary on
his podcast to talk.
Yeah.
It's a good question once and she can
just deny it and people say,
why don't you go talk to him on his
podcast?
Yeah.
With just the two of them in a room.
No.
Moderator,
just the two of them in a row.
Bernie and Hillary make him have a four
hour conversation and just film it.
Yeah.
It just said like,
why,
why does it any candidate just start
their own podcast now it's,
it's w why don't they just
start their own podcast now and just get
out and put it out throughout their
platform?
I burned,
you could talk to be video,
it would have to be video.
You'd have to see their faces because
when someone gets called out on some
shit,
it's like they don't talk about it and
then like the three minutes passes and
they go,
okay,
next.
They're like,
wait,
wait.
We're not done with this answer yet.
Why is this essentially,
it's ridiculous.
It's a ridiculous way to get to know
those people.
Ridiculous way to get to know them,
but it's also like that one subject is
so critical and it was just glossed
over.
She barely responded to what?
So the whole campaign thing just don't,
don't respond to it then don't talk
about thing.
Well,
I mean what did they tell her or not?
Whether she chooses to or not.
The fact is everybody was cool with it.
They just let it slide like that should
be,
you should be like,
stop.
We're not moving on.
Stop the clock.
We're not moving on until you answered
the question.
She talks about how she,
like she was talking tough to those
bankers.
I told them to stop.
What they're doing.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
Show us though.
I told them that.
Cut it out.
All right mom.
That's like what your mom says.
You better not drink tonight.
Cut it out.
Ari.
Young man.
All right mom.
All right.
Cut it out and she's took 250 grand for
them.
Oh,
they don't have enough money.
Cut it out,
but also waste 250 grand on a fucking
speech.
Siri,
Google search.
How to make a bomb.
Hey Siri,
it's so ridiculous,
so ridiculous that you can get paid that
much.
But like,
it's not like she's pink floyd
fucking birthday party.
I knew how to hire pink floyd to play
for your corporate event.
You got to pay a quarter million bucks
and it's going to be an awesome show.
Yeah.
You know they bring lasers.
Who'd you see in a small show once and
you see the guy who just died and a
small show in Vegas once.
Which guy that just stp stone temple
pilots.
I've talked about it a few times.
It was,
must have been cool.
It was Dana White's birthday.
They hired the stone temple pilots for
Dana White's 40th birthday.
Damn cool.
I was like,
damn,
that's like long cash.
As long he was going to do that.
He was awesome for pitch roto hiring
minuto he was going nutty backstage like
backstage.
She was.
Who was that?
Scott?
What's his name?
Died.
Yeah.
Scott.
Nutty.
Nutty,
like crazy demands.
We don't start in five minutes,
we're fucking Outta here.
Like he's,
he was a high strong dude.
It wasn't an easy guy,
but when he went on that fucking stage,
you understood.
They understood.
Like maybe you have to be that crazy to
be that God damn good.
Because when,
when they,
when they started that show and when he
went through that set,
yeah,
there's 200 people in the room and he
did it like there's 50,000 people to
stadium that are freaking the fuck out.
He smashed it.
Helios smashed to Helios.
It was easy.
I liked that when an artist is just
fucking,
yeah,
I'm giving it my all.
I wanted to run out of there and run
back to my hotel room and right after
that,
yeah.
You know,
you see a guy like that and you'd be
like,
oh my God,
he's just,
yeah.
He just was,
it was flawless.
Just smashed it like Damn Ronnie around
on stage using that fucking megaphone.
Like the whole deal.
That motherfucker went hard.
They were good.
They were really good.
I was super impressed.
I got the interview,
I got to uh,
introduce them.
Really?
Yeah.
It was pretty dope.
Like I said,
happy birthday to Dana and it brought up
stone temple pilots and like,
this is the craziest shit ever.
And he went out.
He didn't know they were there.
He didn't even know we were going.
I didn't know I was going to be there.
It was all set up.
The whole Party was like,
uh Oh.
He didn't know that was part.
Oh really?
I had no idea it was gonna be what it
was.
He's like,
Nah,
that's called Joe.
What's going up?
Oh,
what the fuck is on top of pilots?
Yeah.
He didn't know.
We had to like hide it.
He paid for it.
It's like when you're a kid buys you a
present.
Paid for it.
Yeah.
The UFC paid for it,
you know.
But um,
either way it was awesome.
Daddy,
I bought this for you.
I bought it for myself through you.
You are worthy and young daughter.
Yeah.
You bought me something that's so sweet.
That's so sweet.
That guy was a bad motherfucker,
but super troubled with the drugs are
troubled with them.
It goes back to this very like,
you don't really get to that level with
when it's all the same thing.
You don't get a fucking,
you know coke,
coke,
head stripper,
who's going to be a good mom.
You don't get somebody who's that good
an artist.
I'm a musician without some some run in
with it.
Yup.
That's the weird thing about the new guy
took over for a black hole sun.
Who is that?
Chris Cornell.
Who was that Guy I took over?
Black Dude.
Who's the new guy?
Not Chris Cornell.
Chris rutger.
No,
no,
no.
I'm thinking of the wrong wrong guy down
in a hole down in a hole song I was in.
Chains do took over.
Oh really?
Yeah,
because the other guy died.
Right and it sounds exactly like him.
Oh you can't do that.
Well that was the point.
It was like let's have them sing the
songs in the same way and it's all fine,
but this guy is like,
but that's race mixing.
That's gets guy,
but this guy is full of life and hope
and interesting.
Oh,
but then when he sings that song down at
a hole,
you're like,
Oh man,
you do polities I don't think
you could send me all the rest of the
songs.
You know like that guy?
Yeah,
I believe it or not from that new dude.
That's interesting.
You're happy to have the job.
You ain't going to fuck this up.
Probably got an Asian girlfriend,
probably got an ex girlfriend.
She's probably real hot.
He sounds it shows hockey like him.
She's probably one of them Asian
girlfriends with those Mo haircuts where
it's like right above her eyebrow
straight across straight and then low
mow haircuts didn't look bobby and have
a joke like that.
Chinese people say,
how did they get their haircut?
Kind of like mouths.
I think Bobby Slayton for sure,
but like that long silky black hair.
He's got a girlfriend like that.
You know that?
Yeah.
Should I,
down to their ass.
They show up.
They're always in high heels.
Like a hipster accessory.
But Asian girl.
Like an assassin.
Yeah,
super hot assassin.
And some Kung Fu movie.
She's protecting him and she knows moves
stupid hot with like a corset on.
What is your assessment where a
miniskirt can't be the best for
mobility.
Yeah.
And she just has a slight Asian accent.
Just light.
Yeah.
It's first briefly then English.
But like you could hear a twinge of it
and she likes chicks.
I like chicks chicks over.
Uh,
it comes back to his dressing room.
Is three other chicks in there,
baby?
We all have a potty.
Come on baby.
Oh,
by the way,
that's where we're going to talk about
how these artists are taking off stuff
off Pandora.
Oh,
that's what we started talking about.
Spotify.
Yeah.
The,
I think black keys took the stuff down.
Or like you could only have her old
stuff.
Nothing new because they're like,
you're not really paying us well enough.
You only giving us access to New People.
So for a young comedian,
people discover me from Pitt,
from Pandora and spotify for sure.
You know,
but um,
for someone who's got brings them money,
then it's like at this point like you
got to pay these people.
And really pay everybody a fair amount.
It's a great service.
Having something like Pandora or spotify
is great.
It's awesome to be able to,
you don't have to illegally download
anymore.
Right.
You just pretty much get,
but that's only on the idea that
everything's going to be available.
Right.
Well here's the problem.
Is anybody making money off of it?
I'll spotify.
Yeah.
Do you mean does spotify making money?
10 bucks a month.
Subscriptions.
Okay,
so and they do pay some and they have to
pay every artist in the world.
Rugby,
they don't pay that much.
I don't pay very much.
No.
See it's different like streaming
rights,
it's different.
It's not the same as sales.
It's weird.
So like you can have a company that
stream stuff and like the,
the rates that you get paid.
There was a story about like the most
played song on spotify and how much
actually generated.
How much would you guess?
The most played song?
I'm thinking like a Taylor swift kind of
thing like that.
Yeah.
What I would to be fair,
if it's that that played on that kind
of,
we'd want to make like 1 million bucks
off that write something on the alarms,
right?
Yeah.
Or a few hundred thousand thousand 500.
I mean,
you would assume 5 cents a pop.
That's a really valuable thing.
If you're playing it millions of times.
I don't know how many times you're
playing it.
Got Some Camper van Beethoven said that
his stuff has been played way more than
that.
Then,
uh,
purchases.
But then he's like,
but you know,
they'll come see my shows now.
Right.
Cracker on camera.
There's definitely some benefit to it as
far as exposure.
It's not all negative for sure not.
But does Taylor swift need that
exposure?
Right.
So the question is what the UCB did.
They're like,
we're not going to pay you because you
should be honored.
They'll say,
well,
we're just barely getting by.
And then they opened up two new
locations after that.
Yeah.
Those.
As soon as I found out,
those guys don't pay anybody.
I'm like,
he can soccer.
I get your fucking improv troupes.
Not Pains,
but these are comedians and they go,
you should be lucky to perform at the
UCB.
It's like a showcase.
I'm like,
okay,
maybe let's just
say that's true.
Let's say me as a eight year comic when
I was an eight year comic,
like I can get seen there.
Sure.
But aren't you the UCB lucky to have
Silverman,
Sarah Sub Michelle and Zach Alfin acra
show up.
Like it's not just a straight,
we're all lucky to be on spotify.
Right,
exactly.
You know what I mean?
They also need the black keys to be able
to stay relevant.
If all the top musicians,
beyonce and the black keys and arcade
fire,
they'll go,
we're all pulling out there.
Sure.
You know,
keep it,
keep it evers.
Here's seven black listeners broken now.
Oh,
nice way to go.
He goes,
yeah.
Then they're less of place to go for all
music.
No,
I totally agree.
So like just pay fairly
well.
We have to find out how much money they
make and what is it like,
what is the the most played,
the most played song ever.
They just had one that got went over 500
million song,
100 million streams,
what would that be?
Four to $500 million.
5 cents B.
I don't think you get that much.
How it works out though,
cause that just try to figure out the
math in your head a little bit.
Say there's 10 bucks a month,
you have to have a payment for to take
care of the service itself.
Right?
So they say that 30% fee goes to
spotify.
So there's a roughly 70% less than $7
left out of that 10 so it's a different
math if you like,
if you play a song one song or if I
listen to only Ari Shaffir 10 times a
day,
30 days a month,
you would technically get all of my $7
technically.
But it doesn't necessarily work out that
way because if I played one joe Rogan
Song,
he's going to get a little piece of that
too.
But not everyone just listens to one
person.
And you listened to 25 songs a day or in
an end?
In one hour even.
Right.
And a lot of time people just let it
play and the they leave.
So that's like one set some things up
like that where they've tried to game
the system where they've tried to play
someone song,
a new artist multiple times to try to
get them some money.
Oh really?
It doesn't necessarily work out totally
well for them that way either,
but there's just not a lot of money in
it in general.
There's like,
there's not a lot of sales for,
for music and a total,
like I just have a big band.
I liked the def tones that they have a
new album coming out soon.
It just announced a concert in La.
If you buy a ticket to this show,
you get their album for free.
Deftones um,
they've been out for a long time.
This show you at the outfit.
That's an arcade fire did it.
But like when the show is touring for
the books,
but I'm going to get the album anyway.
I'm going to be able listen to all those
songs on Youtube,
on spotify,
Pandora.
They've been around forever.
They're pretty bad ass.
They had some bad ass songs.
Could you tell me
five senses but it's not,
I can't fucking figure this calculator
how it works though.
What he's saying.
I just want to know what it would be on
radio plays.
I'm not mad at you.
The most downloaded song,
well that was,
that was the Ed Sheeran Song like
thinking out loud I think is what it's
called.
500 million in the article compared it
to a youtube would.
They have over 10 songs that have over a
billion plays on it.
How much youtube gets money because
there's ads next testing.
So they're getting money from the ads,
not from people using the service from a
subscriber and they've started
youtube red to try to compete with that
kind of thing too,
which is nine nine nine a month.
James Service thing like that too.
It's interesting.
So there's really probably not that much
money that's even left over for the
artists out of that $7 kind of their
argument and that people are just a lot
of money in and around in general for
it.
All right,
but don't they have like,
what is it called,
an IPO initial public offering that
haven't they do,
they do stuff like that with these kinds
of companies and they sell them and then
tech,
uh,
sector gobbles them up and the stock
market,
they make a of degree and already by the
way.
Okay,
thank you.
Multiple ways.
That's why I'm trying to say there's
deals you can have.
So like a spotify or apple music could
pay,
uh,
drake for his new album to come out
exclusively on apple music.
And that's the best.
That's the only way you can get it.
That's what Kanya is sorta tried to do
with title right now.
Exclusively exclusivity.
So it's like we have it.
No one else has it.
Right.
And then you're like,
well,
if I want,
this is the only way I can get this new
thing.
I got to get Amazon prime or I've got to
get apple play or I got to get this.
I don't like that because everyone has
their own gaming system.
It sucks when it only comes out only on
xbox.
Right.
It's like,
come on man,
we're not going to fucking buy a
playstation.
We already have an x box.
Some people that use android phones,
like my friend Louis unbox therapy,
he was telling me that he avoids using
itunes.
We're having this conversation.
I was asking him about phones today
cause there was a threat of my message
board where people getting mad at Brian
for talking shit about the Samsung
Galaxy s seven and that he was going to
switch over to it,
but I know he switches over to different
phones like every couple of months and
write stories about this Guy Louis.
Oh,
unbox therapy's a website where he said
you got a youtube channel on a website,
but what he does is he,
he reviews tech stuff.
He takes it out of the box and tries it
and he talks about it and he knows a lot
of shit about technology.
He describes,
he's thinks he's describing it from a
very educated point of view and then he
takes that phone.
He's like,
okay,
I'm going to use this as my main phone
for like a month or something like that.
That's just like,
oh fuck,
I didn't realize this problem.
Yeah.
Tell you what's annoying,
what's not.
And he said he doesn't,
even though he uses like Mac computers,
he doesn't use itunes because itunes
specific to one platform and that's
annoying specific warren platform.
Well,
you can't get itunes like you,
you like if you want to use like,
you want to watch movies and shit like
that.
I don't think you can necessarily do
that on a,
on an android phone.
Oh yeah.
A lot of people,
when I tweet my podcast or she first got
to tech,
um,
uh,
they go,
don't give me the itunes link.
I can't use that.
I'm going to android.
Yeah.
It's like 55% of the downloads use
itunes,
but 45% don't.
That's a lot.
Yeah.
I see the most important one.
But it doesn't mean it's the only one.
It's not,
but it's easy to use the other 30% of
your income to,
so if you sell an album for 10 bucks,
itunes gets $3 of that rubber that's not
relevant.
And podcasts,
podcasts,
yeah.
But in like music and sales and stuff.
Right.
And record sales.
It's a big deal.
Yeah,
that's a big deal.
But they do provide that same sort of
service,
it seems like if they take 30% it's
probably similar to how spotify is
talking about.
They take,
I mean they're providing a distribution
labrador down there,
keeping it up and it's a secure,
stable platform that like the
application that comes with your iphone,
you're not going to get any better than
that.
I've had a podcast apps spotify as free
for most people.
Right.
You just have to listen to an ad.
So then they get ad revenue.
Okay,
go ahead David ad revenue and then you
could also subscribe if you like get rid
of,
they get rid of the ads that we can
still make money off you.
We don't have to get the ads every 10
minutes.
So apple does that now too.
They have a streaming music site
service.
So what Louis was saying is he uses
Amazon prime and Google play because
they're not platform specific.
Yeah,
use tweeted a link to a new song,
grimes or something.
He was like,
anybody who put the apple play one on
the go click on it and you're like,
but now I have to pay for apple play to
play it.
And he was like,
man,
that's fucked.
I know thing.
Yeah.
It's annoying.
Like when you go to a website to read an
article and they say they need your
email address first.
Fuck,
I'm out.
But you fuck you.
[inaudible] David Taylor's theory is
that,
that's why anyone still has hotmail.
It's for,
you're like,
sure.
Here's my email address.
Go ahead and use that one.
Yeah.
It's just a spam filter.
Well just for like a website that you
don't give a fuck about.
Yeah.
An email address that you just,
a burner email address.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't think the future is in,
um,
getting people to pay for shit.
I think it's super hard to get people to
pay for shipping for sure.
Well,
it's,
it's the online,
I talked to Aubrey about this a long
time ago and if you're a store
[inaudible],
you know,
and you were buying two shirts,
right.
You know,
and then you're in line right there.
Like you were at starbucks yesterday and
you see these,
uh,
these,
the pad chargers,
like how much did it like 10 bucks.
Like,
Oh,
maybe I'll get one.
Right.
You already got your Wallet Open.
And that was actually more than we were
spending on coffee,
but I didn't buy it.
You didn't buy it,
but it wouldn't be the biggest deal if
you did.
It was a bad example.
But if you're like,
hey,
would you also like this?
I'm socks up.
Yeah,
sure.
I'll get some socks too.
But to open up your wallet is like a way
bigger deal.
Even a 99 cent APP.
A lot of people go like,
well,
let me read the reviews,
you know,
let me look at this as a good app.
You know what I'm talking about?
It's like strange though.
For $1 is you're way less likely to
spend it online.
Then 10 bucks in a store.
It's just hard to get people to actually
open up that eat wallet.
And what,
same thing with email or justice where
it's like,
oh,
I don't want to sign up for this stuff,
man.
Well,
a lot of times you don't have an ego
wall at either.
A lot of times you're just entering in
all the individual credit card
information every time.
That's what I mean.
Like to open up your,
to pay anything online.
But you know,
apple has an [inaudible] wallet.
Oh,
real wallet feature.
Yeah.
While you can actually buy things with
your phone.
Oh,
that stuff now.
And they put,
they came out with,
at first it was android,
right?
Android pay was first and then the apple
player was,
took over.
Whatever the fuck android calls it.
What do they call it?
I don't know.
But they've been doing that on some
phones for a while.
I've seen people buy shit and it's
annoying as fuck be behind them because
it doesn't,
that doesn't eat when you're at the,
uh,
it's okay.
When you had the,
if you've ever seen that,
when they do that at starbucks.
Yeah.
Chai scan,
it fucking doesn't work.
Yeah.
Just stop it as annoying ones in the
middle of a conversation.
Someone's that can get a picture and
you're like,
sure.
And then they're like,
hold on,
hold on.
Let me find out.
Oh,
I got to delete some photos.
it's the worst.
And then align forms.
We're going to say Jamie Disney armband.
I haven't been at the time.
And I've heard,
I've heard some things about this
recently.
There's some sort of like wristband.
You can get a wristband for your kids
when you use it to pay for everything at
Disney.
So we don't take your wallet.
All transactions.
It's getting on your rides.
It's your fast pass or fail.
Yes.
Oh Wow.
The technology,
and I've heard this coming.
I bleed into some other places too.
Whoa.
He just got to set up a perfect
experience for you too.
Well that's one of the reasons why we're
resisting this Apple Watch thing.
That red ban has a chimes off every
hour.
He couldn't figure it out when people
send them text message with chime and
you couldn't figure out how to shut it
off,
figure it out.
No,
that means it's hard to figure out
what's bad.
It's not good.
Right.
He's like,
how's it shut off?
And I'm like,
I don't want my fucking,
because that's where it's going to go,
man.
And then that thing's going to be used
to buy things and then someone's going
to come stand next to you and steal all
your fucking credit card information off
your phone.
They already know how to do that.
This is already a way well,
won't work with Arash fear,
ladies and gentlemen.
You know why?
Cause ours you fear has off flip phone.
I told it to burb what's we're having
this conversation it goes,
yeah,
yeah.
They had cancer.
That dick tie it at the new ones don't
give you the cancer,
that deck.
I don't think he's correct.
I don't know.
I think it's probably exactly the same
amount of radiation.
Well,
you've shown us that was the,
uh,
the Disney magic band is what it's
called.
Oh,
okay.
So it's like a fitbit,
so that,
that kind of a thing.
Yeah.
But there's like,
there's a lot of extra things in it.
It's not just unlocked the door of your
hotel room.
Yup.
Such your key for your car.
Ooh,
whoa.
The thought about that though.
Nobody said,
well,
what are some of the loses it right,
but they probably don't know what your
room is unless you're going to go up and
down the fucking hallways every door.
I went to her room,
I went in there,
tried the key,
open it up,
and then it's just some guys staring at
me from in the bed.
They gave you the wrong thing.
Oh my God.
That's amazing dude.
Staring and I'm like,
sorry.
Um Oh,
it was weird.
That's happened to me before.
Yeah.
Oh,
so anyway,
so they want you to put your podcast on
spotify.
Yeah,
they have podcasts on there now and I've
resisted.
Hmm.
I just don't know if it's a,
I mean you're a precedent set or at some
point,
well it's,
I don't know if it's necessarily
beneficial.
I mean,
I guess more people who are able to have
access to it,
but I don't know.
Do they edit it?
Do they put ads in it?
I don't know about that.
They are expanding.
Are there some uh,
shows you can watch on there and there's
this one video aspect coming through
there.
I liked that fact that it's available as
a regular MP three and you can do
whatever the fuck you want to do with
it.
You could watch it while it's live on
youtube,
can watch it later or you can just
download it.
And if you want to download through
itunes,
go ahead.
If you want to download it through
spotify,
that seems like a different thing
because that's like a service that's
like a new,
it's a company.
It's like,
then you're there,
you're,
you're selling content.
You're like a content provider,
right.
Spotify.
And that's what they are.
They're content providers,
but they don't create,
they're not content creators.
They probably will have actually like
Netflix,
right?
Maybe things like,
well,
if anyone could just get all the,
the videos,
then we have to do something.
Netflix is constantly stepped up
constantly.
I mean from drop shipping.
Yeah.
You know,
cd videos,
dv,
Abrahms,
whatever that is.
Streaming.
Yeah.
And then they go,
ah,
no,
we're,
we're done with that.
Blockbuster.
We'd put you out of business.
And this isn't when people are
downloading stuff too much.
So,
uh,
we'll still do that a little bit,
but let's,
uh,
just get all,
every pretty much entertainment,
every documentary,
every old Sitcom.
Let's just get it all on our thing so
you can come to us and then other people
start going,
well,
why can't we just do that?
You know,
apple tv made the,
made the apple TV,
apple made the appletv and then fx and
people like,
let's pull this stuff back.
Let's make it on our own APP.
You can come to our APP for watch it.
Yeah.
So netflix sees that and like we'd have,
we need a reason for you to come to us.
Let's make house of cards.
Let's make these interesting,
cool shows with no like TV standards
they have to abide by.
LikeF is for family.
Yeah.
When you see a hard curse,
a hard fuck,
you buy a cartoon.
Yeah.
You're like,
what?
Yeah.
It's like,
oh my God.
Not only that,
they can do whatever nudity they want,
whatever they want,
any content they want,
whatever they want to talk about,
they can.
It's up to them with the readiness and
they want to put it out.
They want to tell you,
hey,
be careful of this or they don't want to
tell you.
Let's see herself figured out.
Kid.
They don't have to.
Megan Kelly,
you make it tell you the Santa Claus.
Santa Claus is real kids and he's white.
Is this 2000 and whatever?
Fuck it was when this happened.
15 was that a 15 story?
I think stop.
We can't do this anymore by the way.
I'll be in Tempe,
Arizona this Thursday.
Friday,
Saturday.
Doppler radar.
I like cheese.
Tempe,
Arizona.
The home of my first Netflix special.
I recorded that there in 2005 really?
Yeah man.
The one where I talked about how stupid
Bush was.
Yeah.
They keep playing that now with this
election because I said you know that I
think what happened like after he got
elected a second time,
they were probably sitting in the back
of the room going we can think we go
down.
Oh yeah I remember that pet.
Yeah I remember that bit.
And then boom cause it was a really good
job of
like I have,
I've told you this before,
but using your voice the way you did
that and that bit was like,
it was like four years past and they all
look and they go wait.
It's like that quiet thing,
a pause mixed by quiet instead of just
talking.
They can flex up and down at flection.
You're just really good at it.
Well thank you.
I just put myself in the position of
that actually happening.
That's what I try to like what would it
be like if there really was this cabal
of evil billionaires that's trying to
control the mindset in program the
entire country and they wanted to put a
dumb person office so they could figure
out how dumb people were.
Like,
that was the premise of the joke.
Yeah.
There's only one way to figure out how
stupid people are.
And you can watch the news,
you can see what movies they buy.
But the only real way is to put a dumb
person in as president and see if
everybody freaks out.
Yeah.
Because if they don't freak out,
it's because they're dumber than him.
They don't even know he's dumb.
He's like,
that's a weird thing about being really
fucking stupid.
You don't know what to do with it.
Yeah.
So the only way,
the premise of the bit was the only way
we could really find out how stupid
America was was to put a really dumb guy
in as president.
And there's many,
many really articulate whip,
smart Republican candidates that could
easily make a great leader.
Like,
well,
why would they do that?
They can't find how stupid we are.
If we do that,
that'd be a backup plan.
Let's see if we can get the dummy in
first.
And then after he won a second term,
that's when the bit was like,
I think we can go down there.
So now they are,
uh,
they're using that to illustrate Donald
Trump or something.
Yeah.
Band.
They've made too many comparisons to
presidential candidates.
The Hitler that it's like,
guys,
it does your to kicking doing it.
You said Bush was Hitler.
You know,
that's like look enough,
like the hat comedy premise from hell
from hell.
She's like the strip are from how,
and at some point it's like,
well hell doesn't seem that bad to be
honest.
You're overusing this.
But it was a really easy way to get away
with like saying something's bad.
Like for a long time.
Like in the 80s in particular,
it was a knockout punch.
Everything time.
Yeah.
The something from hell,
I can't believe he's saying how people
back then.
Whoa.
Slow down.
Audrey,
push on steroids
on crack.
Crack is another one.
Yup.
Let's say the same thing,
but say it slightly different.
So it seems like we're original,
right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's still on in one word.
Well,
I mean,
if,
if it's just a very minor part of what
you're trying to describe,
I guess it's fine to use it as a non
creative narrative or noncreative a
descriptive,
but when it's,
when you're doing it a lot,
I think too much
overuse.
Yeah.
I wonder how much this is going to
change everything the way Donald Trump
is running for president.
Well,
here's what I saw from it.
So before,
I mean,
I'm assuming in the Lincoln Times,
you know,
they were just,
the candidates would just say their
opinions,
so what they,
what they thought and that's what the
newspaper print and that'd be the end of
it.
They would go out and talk for hours
too.
Yeah,
sure.
Stomping him,
do whatever.
No,
no microphones.
No microphones.
Wow.
Oh yeah.
No microphones.
Just get up there and talk.
Hopefully the acoustics aren't terrible,
but mostly it's probably outside.
People Fart and take a train to the next
state to try to convince them.
By the time your speech has done,
half the people are dead for malaria,
they just die.
And then it became a thing where like
Bill Clinton went on Arsenio Hall and he
played
a trumpet,
trumpet,
saxophone.
That's what it was.
And his ratings went up like 10 points
over night and we're like,
wait a minute,
this has nothing to do with the issues.
And so there was this mixture of
showmanship and issues and I think
trump's theory,
his thesis is guys,
I don't think the your platform matters
as much as the showmanship.
I think it's only showmanship.
Well also it's who else is running.
Sure.
And what Ted Cruz,
have you seen those videos?
Ted Cruz made?
Yeah,
the commercials when they show the
outtakes,
all,
all the people hugging and stuff.
And the best is the wife,
the,
his mom going like,
she prays for me and she's like,
mm hmm.
He goes,
sometimes,
you know,
hours a day.
She was like,
oh well I don't like the look of like of
hours.
And she goes,
where are you going with us a day?
Just got cut mom.
Mom,
stick to the script.
You shape or pious and I'm not gay.
Right.
And
the old thing is so crazy.
This is like,
I think Bernie's the only one talking
about shit that actually American people
day to day have to deal with.
He's definitely talking more about
social issues.
Yeah.
I would like to talk,
I say socialism,
like it's a bad word,
but it's just social issues.
Well,
yeah,
but socialism isn't just social issues.
Socialism implies some sort of a
community pot of money that we're going
to distribute to people.
Do they distributors that now and we use
80% of it for defense?
Yeah.
Oh well that's just all offense.
But that's the problem that people find
with this.
The big problem that I've heard from
people that actually understand it,
not folks like you and me,
but people that actually understand it,
they're like,
the problem is it just makes government
bigger because what he's doing is
proposing that we get more taxes from
people and somehow or another it's going
to create more programs and that there's
more programs going to trickle down to
the people.
It's like,
but the problem is here's what I
understand,
but you take more taxes from people and
you're just giving it to the government.
And then they have to be competent.
All of a sudden you're never been
competent before.
Right.
There's a Co somebody on my message
board brought this up,
like the Department of fish and game
that I always praise them for the
conservation efforts that they've done.
They've got all big wildlife biologists
running it.
Right.
You know,
like these are like actual scientists,
not a writer.
Ocracy they hired some really smart
people care about the environment to run
these fish and wildlife department.
So let's say people say like that would
never work and go,
okay,
fine.
Maybe like how's it has no,
but here's the,
here's the reality.
What we have now is not working.
People are getting poorer and poorer.
See,
wildlife biologists are very different
than economist.
Yeah.
So when you get a wildlife biologist,
it's trying to manage the buffalo
population and they try to figure out,
hey,
you know,
we've got wolves in yellowstone that are
killing the buffalo.
We've got to figure out how to do it.
And then they try to find work arounds.
They do all sorts of different things to
try to maintain healthy populations.
There's no profit in that.
So profit.
Yeah.
See now the problem with anything
economic is there's all sorts of
motivating factors that lead up to rules
that get past that allow these people
that become president or become,
you know,
whatever the fuck they're doing,
where they're making deals with people
like the bankers that are paying Hillary
Clinton $250,000 they get them into
these positions and then they can,
they can profit insanely.
They get these positions on these,
these guys go from,
this guy was a great,
it's a great documentary called inside
job and it's all about the Wall Street
collapse and this guy who was like this
very educated financial guy is
interviewing these people and picking
them apart as he's interviewing them and
you see,
they start to panic and they start to
freak out and some of them go on,
you know,
I'm going to only have one more
question.
Then I'm going to leave in the beginning
of the interview of they're all smiles
and happy and these are economists and
he finds out that these guys who were
economy professors went on to get jobs
with these banks.
So they set these rules like,
well we've chest checked with the,
you know,
Blah Blah Blah University economics
department and they recommend this,
that and that.
So they get,
they move into cushy jobs where they get
paid millions of dollars once they
leave.
These government positions are these
teaching positions?
Very,
very fascinating stuff.
Cause it shows there's motivation and as
soon as there's motivation for profit,
everything gets girly.
So Clinton can say all day and have some
cash.
I'm like,
well I'll try to,
Clinton can say all day that she has,
they don't influence her.
Well then they don't take on nature.
Yeah.
You can't take that much money to talk.
I don't know.
I do know it's like I don't,
we,
neither one of us really understand it,
but I don't see Bernie as a guy was
like,
let's just do our morning.
I'm sure it'll work out well.
It's not about impression.
It's not about,
it's not bad for,
they're trying to,
not that I would like Mrs. Clinton,
but Talos,
what are those transcripts,
but I think they have that work thought
out.
Well it's,
it's tricky man.
When you have a lot of money like that,
hundreds of thousands of dollars and
someone's paying you to talk for an
hour,
that is absurd.
That's absurd.
It doesn't make any sense.
And they have transcripts of it.
I guess it won't show up.
She won't,
she won't release them.
The whole thing is very bizarre shit.
Right?
That's her normal thing.
She hides her email.
She was like,
oh,
I didn't know it wasn't allowed to use
regular emails for this stuff.
Oh,
you guys aren't allowed to fly that.
Well,
here's one of the things that I'm,
Mike Baker was talking to me about and
he's a former CIA operative,
has been on the show before.
He runs a security company now and he
said,
if that was me,
which she did,
he goes,
well,
I would be in jail.
What if I did what she did?
Private emails using a private email
address and sending top secret
information through that email address.
He goes,
I'd be in jail.
He's like,
she had an email server in her bathroom.
Not only that,
but the guy who set up that email server
just got immunity from federal
prosecution.
Wow.
So she's already in this protected group
of people.
They were like,
we can pretty much do whatever he wants.
It's squirrels,
Ville,
man hole things.
Squirly like they're not even try.
She's in the middle running for
president.
She at the lead of the Democratic
nomination and she's involved in to
criminal
investigations.
She says Christ.
Yeah.
And they're just like,
let's just not talk about that.
Well,
it's like this is all they have and when
this is all they have,
I mean there's no one else.
Who the fuck else is there?
There's Bernie Sanders and Hillary
Clinton.
Period.
That's it.
That's it on the democratic side.
We haven't heard a peep of anybody else
since.
All right.
Who else?
Everybody's gone.
They're all gone.
It's just them.
So it's,
it's one of those things where
everybody's shutting the fuck up because
they think they have to.
This is the last gasps of a dying
system.
This is the last gasps of a ridiculous
dying system that is set up because it
was back.
The system is fighting back then was set
up back when people wrote with feathers,
slinger when we had congress,
because I couldn't afford to travel from
Nashville all the way up to Washington.
So we have our congress goes for us,
they speak for us,
so we have to,
but man,
we have email and phones.
We don't need you to go there for and
why do you have a job?
It needs to be restructured.
Restructured.
Yeah.
Well it needs to be restructured to that
from scratch.
The technology at the technology and the
access to people that's available today
because government should be,
people should have to have some level of
education to understand the parameters
of what they're talking about,
what they're voting on.
Yeah,
we don't,
we're not even getting the information
to it.
There's so much waste.
We are government has got a virus and
it's not being cured.
I,
I talked to these guys who were defense
contracts work for defense contractors
in Iraq and Afghanistan and one of them
had been in the military before.
They both been with the military when
they didn't a pinch pinto cartridge.
They don't order petro cartridges.
They order a new printer,
take out the printer cartridge and shred
the new printer.
What?
Yeah,
and there's no repercussions for that
because no one has to be like,
did they do that?
It's a,
it's easier or to order it that way.
What I,
there's no reason for it,
man.
It's all fucking wasteful.
The these guys high as fuck when they're
telling you this.
No,
they weren't like,
dude,
he's going to go on a podcast to talk
about this too high to remember the
specific details,
but that's one of them and it's like,
dude,
we're just,
it's just as bureaucracy.
It's just corrupted and the governments
in and now it's like,
I dunno Obama,
he just won't talk about,
he's done some great shit,
but he just won't talk about the drone
strikes about wedding parties in Yemen
where we're not even at war with just
killing random people.
And our official quote is like,
let's just not talk about it.
But gay marriage is legalized and
that's,
yeah,
man,
that's great.
You can't just murder people.
More people have big died on a drone
strikes under him then Bush.
Yeah,
way more.
Well,
there's more drones now.
They're way better too.
There's still killing innocence and
we're just not talking about it.
Yeah,
I mean they can arrest people now.
Never tried them.
Well they've also,
NSA has more power than they've ever
had,
cause Feinstein didn't just restructured
it.
They also used to shoot at metadata.
I don't know if they still do that,
but they used to shoot like we're a
phone is.
Oh really?
So if you're a real bad guy and you're
hanging out in an apartment building and
your phone happens to be there,
that's what you're shooting at.
Oh,
shooting missiles at that phone hoping
somebody else has the phone,
then it's like,
it's acceptable casualties at the phone
in the bedroom.
Oh,
we took that bedroom out.
What?
That was Americans,
we wouldn't do that because we value
American lives.
Are innocent,
lives over innocent.
Um,
you get many lives.
It will,
it's just way more convenient when they
don't look like us.
They don't talk like us and they dress
weird.
It's way more convenient to light them
up with rocket.
This is why,
uh,
the British were smart when they
colonized Africa.
Um,
they put,
uh,
east Indian people,
Indians from,
from India.
They put them in charge.
So the Africans hated the oppressors.
Hated people who,
you know,
dominated him,
conquered them.
No one likes people.
No one likes being conquered.
It's just not a thing.
Went to a couple of girls that ran in
there,
and so they're like their face of who
they hate it with these Indians who also
had been conquered,
move over there.
Right?
So there's really no terrorism on
British soil from the African Milton's
because they don't hate that white face.
Well if we went to war with say Russia
today,
they look just like just like us.
This is harder.
Yeah.
Luckily they were coats.
Maybe we'd find out that the
government's photoshopping their faces
and stretching them out to make them
look more like look at those oval heads.
Yeah.
What does that,
um,
which rue salon pro pro pro pro
providing the cough is one of the top,
uh,
boxers and I think he's won 54.
One 47 one,
four,
seven.
Come on providing a coffee.
He's an animal animal.
Oh yeah.
He's,
they call him the Siberian,
something around in Siberian express it
overhead.
Yeah.
His,
his is,
it might seen his first name wrong.
Yeah.
He,
um,
he takes unbelievable amounts of
punishment is what he looks like.
But look at him.
See,
he looks just foreign enough.
You know what that is?
Yeah.
He's got some Asian in him.
Well,
he's got a Russia,
I think he's got Mongolian in Mongolia.
It's probably why he's such a fucking
warrior.
He's probably descendant of Ganga Iskcon
or some shit.
Yeah.
He didn't look Russian.
Well,
the,
the um,
the Mongols conquered Russia for like
200 years.
Really?
Yeah.
The Mongols came in in the winter in
Russia and unexpectedly and fucking took
over.
He looks like toby,
the front bar tender a little bit.
Yeah.
That's funny as fuck.
That guy's an animal man.
He's a fucking animal.
Ooh.
Yeah.
He's fun to watch.
He's super aggressive.
So let's talk about this rematch.
Which one?
Nate Diaz and conor Mcgregor.
What are they fighting at 55?
I do not know.
I don't think that's been solidified.
I believe that connor is asked for it to
take place at 70,
which is where he was,
but he can say like,
I can do this exactly the same way and
then it won't be a factor,
you know?
But also I think he was really healthy
at one 70 and I think you'd like it was
connor.
I can think you felt great leading up to
the camp and leading up to the fight.
He just had a bad game plan and his
ground Game Kinda got exposed to weight
classes above where you want to tie two
weight classes.
It's not true.
First of all,
they both weighed in almost exactly
the same.
No two way classes above where he won
his title.
Yes.
But not really.
All it is is they're not cutting weight.
It's too,
but he's not whiting.
Right.
But he's not fighting like Damien Maia
who used to fight at two oh five or one
85 and he's cutting down title shot and
listen that title shots where it's like
you don't deserve title shot on two
weight classes above you.
It's just a nate diaz fight.
Well this isn't a title shot.
I'm saying at least.
It's like,
well,
you know the whole story behind it,
there was a fallout Hofeld dos Anjos is
the lightweight champion was supposed to
be fighting conor mcgregor.
He breaks his foot 11 days before the
fight.
Nate Diaz takes the fight on a drop of a
hat.
No training whatsoever.
I mean fucking none.
He hasn't done anything.
He was at the store.
Yeah,
he was hanging,
hanging out and uh,
nate,
you know,
posted pictures afterwards of him
drinking Tequila and hanging out in
Mexico eating tacos and shit.
So he was just having a car,
nine bitch.
He's just living his life.
Right.
But he's in such good shape that he can
get away with that because he does so
much triathlon training.
He's constantly biking and swimming and
running.
He entered into a bunch of triathlons.
He's in very good shape and so he was
able to pull it off cause his cardio
base was so good and just,
he's a fucking damn good fighter.
He's a damn good fighter.
And he signed too and he's fought
legitimately at one 70 twice.
He lost,
he lost a stun gun,
Kim.
And he also lost a Roy McDonald at one
70 these are the legitimate one.
Seventies and Roy being one of the best
ones.
70 world.
Yeah,
he got ragdolled a little bit by rory,
but you know that was a wake up call for
him.
He went back to one 55 and at one 55 in
his last fight against Michael Johnson,
he put on probably the best performance
up to the conor mcgregor fight,
the best performance of his career.
He was fucking sensations.
When I view Nate Diaz,
I view,
I think of him as a 50 fiver.
He,
that's what he usually competes at.
But for this fight,
like he didn't want to have to cut
weight 2011 days out.
It's a little heavy.
So he says,
look,
let's make it at one 70 they both agree.
Nate Wade,
one 69 konner weighed one 68 or maybe
vice versa.
I think that's it though.
So I mean they're basically the same
size.
What will they find out?
Well,
they fought at one 70 what do you mean
when nate said,
I'll fight it once every,
where was he walking up?
Probably a little heavier than that.
He probably died it and worked out real
hard for seven or eight days of the 11
cockpit on the last couple.
No,
connor didn't have to cut anything.
I mean,
if he cut anything,
it probably a couple of pounds.
So,
which is not tied,
you just don't eat.
That happens.
But there's not even 10 pounds
different.
So the same way,
like when they got into the octagon,
I guarantee you they're within a pound
or two of each other.
But nate is longer and taller and he's a
very good boxer.
Like nate's bars on a regular basis with
Andre Ward,
who was one of the best pound for pound,
if not the best pound for pound box or
in the world.
Now that Floyd Mayweather,
quote unquote retired.
Andre Ward is a motherfucker and he just
fought this Saturday night on hbo and I
just watched it the other day.
Um,
on Dvr.
It's fucking amazing.
He's so good,
dude.
He's such a,
he's just nasty and he's now he's
fighting at one 75 he's going to fight a
survey.
Sergey who's like the best one,
75 are in the world.
So he fought nate spars with that guy
that day on a regular basis,
like their friends.
And you know nate also spars his brother
Nick,
cause one of the best strikers in the
UFC.
Definitely one of the best boxers.
You know,
he's a very good boxer.
And,
and he also spars with Joe Schilling all
the time.
Who is a glory world champion kickboxing
world champion.
He's a motherfucker man.
So Neda sparring with like high level
world class striker like legitimate.
Andre Ward,
Joe Schilling,
two world champions and two respective
disciplines.
So He's,
he's a bad motherfucker.
I just think that people,
he seems swearing and stick it up his
double fingers and they don't realize
all that.
Put all that shit aside and observe his
movements,
observe his movements in a fight like in
the Michael Johnson fight in the,
uh,
the gummy fight in the markets.
Dave fight in the gray maynard fight.
Observe his movements.
He's a motherfucker dude.
When he tees off on you,
he comes at you like a snake.
He's got long ass on connections of all
time where it's like 80% of us strucks
hit strikes in the first round.
He Lit Donald Up.
It was like,
what the fuck it,
nothing missed.
He let Donald Up.
He fucked on all up in that first round.
Donald Donald Donald started coming back
with leg kicks.
The only guy who's ever really
successfully like put him away in the
UFC was Josh Thompson and Josh Thompson
is one of the most underrated guys.
He's,
he's Josh Thompson when he was at his
best left to go over to strike force.
And a lot of people missed out on some
of the fucking wars that he had over
there.
And the Gilbert Melendez fights over
there and he went through,
you know,
a lot of wear and tear on you.
But like skill for skill.
Josh Thompson is a mother Fucker,
but he's now,
he's like 36 time just starts to get
everybody.
But at his best.
And I think that like his last fight
with Nate Diaz when he head kicked,
I mean stopped him.
It was one of like his best performances
ever.
And then you had some losses after that,
but it can't,
it's like it's hard to stay healthy and
get through a camp when you're 36 years
old.
When those guys get to the late thirties
things start to get.
So he has one loss.
But the loss in my opinion,
I mean one stoppage loss,
but the loss to Thompson's like,
well he's one of the most underrated
guys.
So it's like solid loss.
Fuck yeah,
it doesn't get,
doesn't get looked at as solid as it
should be.
I think Thompson at its best is,
he's a motherfucker.
So if,
okay,
so let's say he's a natural one 70,
or let's say he wants to fight the
conor,
but he's not,
he's not,
he just wants to fight this fight at one
70 and prove his point that he would
appoint to fight exactly the way they
did it before and to come in and fight
in a bar.
This is what happens if they're going to
do that in the meantime,
there's lit frankie than Aldo fight for
a title I long ago or vacate the belt
that you haven't defended once.
Max Holloway should be in the mix as
well.
You know,
I think they also offered,
although a shot at Mcgregor and he
didn't take it,
that could be a Brazilian thing,
if you know what I mean.
Who else?
Okay.
You made the injection like heroin,
they'll do that.
They still do that.
Uh,
I would say it was more like he's just
an unprepared and out of shape and they
want to get knocked out again.
I mean,
the guy just knocked him out with want
to fucking punch a couple of months ago.
I remember it got,
but I mean,
he's like,
give me that rematch because we can be
mentioned.
No,
see,
he didn't know that connor was going to
get worked when Connie got worked by
Nate Diaz.
It changed the whole game.
Is there.
Oh,
I can pick this guy.
Everything changed,
man.
Everything changed in everyone's
approach to him.
When you watch a guy get beat up and
strangled like that,
you gotta pee again.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Do it.
Talking about this.
Don't worry about it man.
But my point is for the folks listing,
when you watch a guy get beat up,
like conor got beat up against nate and
he shoots for a take down and then gets
taken down naked on top of them,
beats him up and then chokes him a taps
real quick.
Like nate just dominated.
And once it got to the ground and he was
already hurt when it got to the ground,
then everybody goes,
hmm,
okay.
Could Hofeld dos Anjos do this?
Could.
And for a guy like conor,
I think one of the reasons why he wants
his fight back is to prove that he
fucked up,
that he tried to take nate out with big
power bombs.
He gassed out,
he got tired,
and then nate boxed him up in the second
round.
Nate start tagging him,
had him hurt and had them shoot for a
take down.
So a guy like conor,
you don't get to be that good.
You don't get to be that far.
You don't get to be that successful.
You don't get to knock out all though
with one punch and beat the fuck out of
[inaudible] in the first round,
like you called it and beat the shit out
of seaver and stop Chad Mendez when you
wanted to bet millions of dollars on it.
I mean,
he's a legit 100% motherfucker.
But the game does not care about
personalities.
The game does not care about confidence.
He actually doesn't,
Huh?
To interaction of fists and face and
chokes and next and kicks and bodies.
It does not care about anything other
than what works.
So like when you see a loss,
like a Rhonda Rousey getting knocked the
fuck out by Holly Holm,
it does not mean that Ronda rousey
sucks.
It does not mean that Holly Holm is the
greatest ever.
It just means that the game doesn't give
a fuck who you are.
It doesn't care.
You want to charge face first at a
counter striker and she clips you with
that first punch.
You're already at CEC or already at
check,
you got rocked like the first punch and
then you're getting beat up for four and
a half minutes after that and then the
second round comes around.
You don't even know where the fuck you
are.
Your ears are going.
You can't see your fucking eyes are
blurry.
Must be so terrifying.
That's what I love about UFC as opposed
to boxing.
Nobody goes 29 to no,
no.
I mean if you go six in a row,
that's like wow.
That's why John Jones,
it's so spooky.
Yeah.
Nobody's beating Jon Jones.
Jon Jones.
Jon Jones has one loss and it's a
disqualification.
It's Matt Hamill and,
and where he was caressing him on top of
them.
And it was a,
it's a dumb rule.
So like 12 to six elbows from on a clock
face.
If you drop an elbow down from 12 to
six,
the people that made the rules thought
that that's somehow another,
it was dangerous.
It's no different than any other kind of
elbows.
It's just a rule.
Yeah,
it's stupid rule.
It's a rule that they put in place
because the people that were on the
commission,
this is coming from big John McCarthy
himself.
The people that were on the commission
at the time,
they,
um,
they thought that if you dropped a 12 to
six elbow,
like those espn karate shows go,
he can break bricks and shit.
You could kill somebody.
So they,
uh,
they made it illegal.
Meanwhile,
it's not even 12 to six.
It's like one to seven.
It's stupid.
He really,
I can fight again.
It's really almost never 12 to six.
It's always a slight angle,
but either way it's fucking dumb.
It's a dumb rule.
It doesn't make any sense.
Yeah.
Um,
by the way,
we have nate Diaz calling indoors sports
podcasts.
Punchdrunk sports id really will picnic
this.
Oh,
Nate Diaz fake.
They always call.
I'm glad you had to fake.
How good are they?
The big ones.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Really because of the accents are great
and they talked about it.
Two Oh nine somewhat.
They're always talking about they're
going pontoon boat shopping
man.
You come on,
come on.
I got to hear a man.
They're great.
It's Danish.
No,
Neil.
And they're so fucking good at it.
For a while they were dating Ronda
Rousey and GSP was all upset about it
because he wanted to date Ronda Rousey
and they,
they catfished him and buried him and
buried him on a,
uh,
on a,
a refrigerator box and the desert.
He got out and now gsps addicted to
kitty litter,
tick kitty litter and computer spray.
These addictions,
doctor,
the aliens all the time.
They told me I missed the two.
I'm two minutes my life.
That's hilarious.
Is that on youtube anywhere?
Uh,
no.
Not Youtube but punch drunk sports.com I
think we get clips.
A daily motion was,
I think they're all open daily motion,
Dave,
any of that stuff?
Yeah,
we got a click that shit and put it on.
Yeah.
Why don't you have clips?
I just don't like,
yeah.
I mean there's no,
I can't give you a good reason that this
is the reason why I think the rematches
is huge.
Okay.
This is why you have to do it.
First of all,
because conor mcgregor up until that
fight,
is one of the most spectacular fighters
ever attached to this boy talking about
him.
Yeah.
Just the spectacle in that sense of
spectacular.
The guy gets on stage and screams at the
winds and the crowd goes nuts.
The Irish flags are more galvanized the
nation.
And I don't even know what galvanized
means.
It means like a coating when you get
nail so they don't rust.
Okay.
Um,
he's spectacular.
Right.
And his results inside the ark got
other.
Nate Diaz fight had been incredibly
dramatic.
Mid Second round,
I'll cut him with an uppercut and
knocking about,
and then it's like,
what?
But when a guy like nate Diaz beat you
and beat you the way he beat you,
the bright thing to do is to have a
rematch.
And this why?
Because the rematch is where the big
money's at.
The brea match with Nate Diaz is God
damn scrooge.
Mcduck gigantic die.
Huge.
2 million plus paper view the eyes.
It's still on the table.
Like if it goes,
let's just say he goes to 45 then maybe
55 again,
there's always going to be like,
well,
I mean they will beat you.
You know.
Exactly.
Not only that,
but here's the problem.
What Frankie might beat him.
Sure.
Holloway.
Max Holloway might beat him in a
rematch.
Who knows?
Yeah.
Jose Aldo might beat him now.
Now the Josie especially Julie all know
Josie Aldo.
Yeah.
It just comes and real healthy.
Know what I'm saying?
If he
chose a,
although he is a fucking nine year
undefeated all time,
great fighter who got clipped with one
big punch.
So what if Aldo fights like in a similar
way to how Meesha tate fought.
Holly Holm takes his time.
Where's that motherfucker out and like
round two or three and just stays in the
outside and leg kicks the shit out of
him.
If all though just chooses to have,
I mean all it was so mad.
He tried to take his head off with a
left hook and he got clipped.
He load it up and he got clipped.
But what if he doesn't do that?
What if he goes in there and play slow
on the outside?
Starts kicking his legs?
What if he initiates a clinch?
Cause let me tell you something about
all those Jujitsu.
It's fucking world class like you watch
or Aldo versus Mike Brown in the UFC a
or the WEC rather.
When he wanted a welterweight,
they'll featherweight title can't get
anything.
Right.
When he won the featherweight title to
it,
he takes his back like a fucking world
champion.
It's smashes him.
I mean this is what Anderson did when he
was at his best was he would get booze
and the first and second round and he's
just almost like this says,
what'd you to fucking relax?
I'm about to knock this guy out.
Different style though.
But I mean it was like,
I'm not going to push.
I will wait and I will get you when it's
time to help continue to win.
Well,
Anderson has a very unique style.
His style is,
he's got a lot of Moyie Thai,
but he also has a lot of traditional
martial arts as well.
Like some of the things that he does,
like the front kick to the face,
the way he does a front snap kick.
It wasn't like a Meu type push kick or a
team.
It was like a karate style kick was on
acid for that fight.
Dude at the MGM and I sit next to each
other on acid screaming when he kicked
him in the face.
Like that dude,
that was a spectacular,
there was the first time we'd ever seen
a front kick to the face.
Kao in the UFC.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that'd be tour.
Stunning.
So Anderson was a sniper and what he
would do is he would find your range,
find your timing,
and then he would unload on shows.
I can go a little close.
Yeah,
close look.
Okay,
now I'm in my ranch or you know,
with different fighters who fought,
fought a different style like with rich
Franklin.
He overwhelmed were in the clinch like
rich Franklin didn't have an answer to
is what's called a plum.
That's when a guy grabs the back of your
head like this and pinches down with his
forearms.
And uh,
the MEU Thai clinch.
Like when like anything else,
there's levels to it.
And it's one of those things where,
you know how,
this is a good way to describe it.
You know,
you tie your shoes and you tie your
shoes effortlessly,
just reached down and cause you've done
it your whole life.
You are pathway like the neuromuscular
pathway to tying your shoes is
automatic.
There's certain movements that become
like that.
Like when you're,
you're sparring or you're fighting in
particular,
sometimes you'll move out of the way and
you're throwing a counter before you
even realize you're doing it.
Like it's too fast for you to even think
about.
But you've,
you've carved that path so deeply in
your neuro muscular structure that when
someone does this,
you do that.
When you see this,
you counter there,
you understand,
you recognize openings without even
being conscious of it.
And when,
when a guy gets in those grooves,
when you get in those groups,
it's very hard to,
to deal with it if you don't have that
groove.
And Anderson had that groove when it
came to that Moy Thai clinch.
She could see it the way he was holding
onto him,
pushing those fights and Chai or yeah,
that's Thai kickboxing fights and it's
one of the things out there punching a
kicking,
but they did that throw,
it almost doesn't seem like it that much
damage.
Oh it does.
It's what's humiliating.
And he was more like the,
the wind knocked out of you.
You know,
if the guy kicks your legs out from
under you and slams you on your back,
you're getting the wind knocked out of,
you can get your,
you're injured,
you could get your shoulder's injured,
you can get your ribs injured,
your neck can get injured if you follow
the wrong way or you get knocked on the
way down.
And in some organizations you can kick
them in the face.
On the way down to,
well,
they'll flow.
So they'll throw kicks and then as you
are scrubbed before the referee gets to
you,
they'll fucking knew you in the face as
you're going down,
even with your gloves touching the
ground,
it's like legal and a lot of
organizations to knee or even kick you
in the face.
Wow.
So you got to read the funding herself.
I just thought I'll just follow the way
that we're going to brace myself.
[inaudible] has some crazy approaches.
Fun though.
They're clench.
Work is like one of the most
underappreciated aspects of the sport
because everybody thinks of it as a
striking sport is,
but it's also grappling sport because
when they tie up inside that clinch,
the guys who are really good,
they,
they execute these nasty trips and they
also the way of manipulating you into
knees and like when someone has a cold,
they clamped down and they know how to
control your neck.
It's a very confusing feeling if you're
not accustomed to it from a high level
practitioner because you get locked and
you don't know what to do.
You start grabbing at it and you're
getting need and the body and then you
get kneed in the chin.
And you said that's one of the most
brutal things whenever the whole crowd
gets behind it too,
and they can start growing news news as
soon as that clinched comes in and they
all want to see it.
Well Anderson kneed him in the face.
He's destroyed,
were tranquil ins knows retracted,
had to get his nose completely
reconstructed.
I mean it was,
it was devastated after that.
Hers.
Oh Man,
those were the wwe pull up rich
Franklin,
um,
Anderson Silva versus rich Franklin once
he,
if you could find that anywhere that the
Kao Anderson Silva Kaos Rich Franklin
the first fight because it was a
masterclass.
No,
I don't think so.
I was at his very first fight in the
UFC.
You might've been,
it might've been.
Yeah,
pull it back though.
So it was definitely the actual match.
They'll pull it back so you can see the
actual of the niece of the face before
he is,
get him in the clinch.
And there's like scared.
Yeah,
well he starts doing this.
He starts moving them around and
manipulating,
seeing,
so Richard's trying to punch him,
but look how he manipulates him with
these fucking knees.
And the clinch just,
he never lets that clinch go.
Boom,
look at this.
He just holding onto the back his neck.
See I was doing with his left hand and
he's needing his body and then he grabs
a hold of it with two hands.
Look at this.
Boom.
Look at that.
Boom to the body so we can toss them
around to the body and he's sliding
around.
And when rich goes to punches,
outmaneuvering him,
he's getting his shoulders in play.
So his shoulders are blocking these wide
looping punches.
And then he's just leaning his hips back
and forcing them to like to absorb these
knees to the body.
And each one of them is Wiki a more and
more and more.
And Boom,
look at these.
Boom again and that balance to the chin.
Boom,
boom,
and there's a combination.
He grabs him again,
boom.
And to the chin,
boom to the legs,
boom to the body and the ways moving
them in a manipulating a man.
This is some high level shit and you
just didn't at the time see this level
of more tie in a,
in mma it was very rare to see,
at least from this position,
is a very rare position to see prolonged
in an MMA fight up into this point.
So there is,
nose is just shattered and now Anderson
just moving in for the kill and he gets
it again.
Boom.
It hits him in the temple and that's it.
It's over.
That's it.
And his nose was destroyed.
I mean destroyed.
It was like on the other side of it.
So you can see right there.
You could see,
yeah,
that's when he took the title.
But back it up just a little bit Jamie.
You can see the nose,
you can see it.
What?
No,
a little bit more like right there.
Let it go right there.
Why Watch when he look at his nose,
it's cave at the top.
There's no bridge.
The bridge,
no,
it's completely smashed.
Ah,
as knows was never the same again.
He had to get a nasal reconstruction
surgery and it was a big deal and they,
they,
you have to,
you know,
put splints on your fucking back up.
They came back or fought him again.
Fought Anderson again,
got beat up again.
Just [inaudible].
He did his best.
He fought well and he fought,
fought great fighters.
I mean rich Franklin had some great
wars.
Vandelay Silva in the UFC knocked out
chocolate down as low as five.
Oh,
chuck was later.
Chuck was his last fight.
The last fight in the UFC.
They have a broken arm.
He knocked out chuck.
Yup.
Or fuck it.
I got one shot go for chuck broke his
left arm with the kick.
Chuck kick.
Fucking aw,
hard.
That's some good fights in that.
Oh my God.
But that was like the first time we'd
seen that level of that clinch in a
world championship level fight.
You never seen anybody control someone
for that long with a Thai clinch.
It was like Wah.
So Anderson was like responsible for a
lot of innovation.
A lot of firsts and not necessarily
innovation in that he's using like
pretty standard traditional techniques
for that respective art form.
Like a front kick is the most standard
technique ever.
But oddly enough,
there was no front kick Kaos until he
knocked out vitor Belfort.
It's amazing when you see that and then
it opens up.
Skateboarding has that too where it's
like someone will do it.
Everybody goes,
oh,
let's all do that.
Yeah.
When Leonardo knocked out,
uh,
randy coture with a jumping front kick
to the face,
everybody was like,
oh,
in Toronto and from like 60,000 people.
That's a big one.
Yeah.
When are they going to do the garden?
I don't know where they can do it now.
It's just recently got past,
but just to finish up this Frankie Edgar
thing,
Frankie Edgar could beat him if,
if he can get taken down and dominant
like that with nate.
Frankie's a goddamn tornado.
Frankie.
I agree.
I do too.
For getting left out there.
Like there's a,
there's a title eliminator fight and now
it's been like,
I guess not a year,
but like,
well where this title shot?
He did what he had to say.
You said when this and you got a title
shot financially though,
you got it.
You got to understand their point of
view.
Okay.
But in the meantime,
although edgar interim title,
yeah.
Or Max Holloway.
Max Holloway's in the mix as well.
I can sue the jump.
Edgar.
It could wah,
it would be either hot ball.
You know what I say?
You got to get all doorframe actually
you've got to give all the pretty much
nine straight years,
no losses.
You got to let them fight again.
Right.
Of course.
That's not a rematch.
Nofziger I'm saying like title who is
either against a connor or whoever.
Okay.
Yeah,
I agree.
Like he's a number one contender.
That's a good call.
Or You could set up a fight.
We're frankie fights Max Holloway or the
other eliminator.
Yeah.
The problem with Dafydd is then you get
rid of like one of the contenders.
Yeah.
If,
if it actually comes to pass,
I feel like he's already done that title
eliminator thing he wanted,
he did what he's asked to that half Max
Holloway fight the winner of Aldo.
Um,
Frankie,
the real problem is a financial problem
because the money with Nate Diaz is
going to be so God damn gigantic.
But in the meantime also had that fight.
But the problem is one of those guys
keep,
get lost and get beat up.
It's,
it's true.
did you have three pieces in play at one
45?
I agree with you,
but I'm saying like the real,
the smart move really is you tell connor
he has to pick a weight class and if you
want to fight at one 70,
you got to give up your 145 pound title
and they fight for the real title,
not for the interim title.
That's,
that's the real thing.
Like just give up your title,
give it up.
John Jones had to give up his title
because illegal problems,
right?
Yeah.
So something,
I had to give it up because uh,
er Aldo had to give it up because he
couldn't fight for awhile.
What?
Well,
no,
he never did get it and give up a
steady,
they,
in terms of being trump,
fuck the interim.
Just give up your title.
You know,
it doesn't matter.
It's not a loss.
The loss to nate Diaz,
you want to go to one 70 that means you
campaigning there.
You can't just freeze up the division.
So then you have Aldo versus frankie for
the real fucking title.
And they fought already before,
by the way.
Although frankly,
yes and although beat Frankie and was
doing Aldo in his prime,
but I think that Frankie is better right
now than he was then.
And I think that he's got some key wins.
Fights.
He's not supposed to win.
That's all he keeps doing and doing it
do.
It just keeps winning fights.
He's not supposed to win.
Well,
he wins fights.
He's supposed to win too.
Oh yeah,
you're right.
Faber fight.
I mean Frankie still start,
he makes his name on these fucking Bj
fights and at these all these fights,
it just like,
Nah,
I didn't have a chance.
And they just keep doing it.
The Cub Swanson fight was a overwhelming
fight and then the Chad Mendez knock
out,
he knocked out Chad Mendez with one
punch.
He's at the top of the heap in my
opinion.
So I think that a rematch was not,
it's not a bad idea between frankie and
Aldo for the title and you have that on
an undercard of a UFC 200 or whatever
the fuck you've been hotter,
want someday to come back to 45 and it's
like sure man will give you a title
fight right away.
It's not like connor is not going to
know that.
He already beat Aldo and knocked him out
with one punch.
He could talk all kinds of mad shit for
the rematch.
They could do it,
run it all back again.
If all though can get past frankie.
Yeah.
So it's just a lot of fun stuff that can
happen.
But the nate diaz fight has to take
place because here's my point was this
is my final point,
is that if he beats nate diaz,
he silences everybody.
If he goes out there and he fights smart
and he sniped him and he stays the fuck
away from the boxing,
he uses a lot of leg kicks.
The Way dos Anjos did takes the front,
cause nate stands real heavy on the
front leg.
His front leg will be his right leg and
connor is a southpaw.
So set connor will be throwing a hard
left leg kick from the back leg.
It's a good setup for him in that
regard.
And then I'll also,
connor knows now he can't knock me out
with one punch.
So when we go,
so he's not going to load up and try to
uncork.
He's going to try to fight smart.
So in fighting smart,
then he'll be able to incorporate leg
kicks and he'll be able to incorporate,
uh,
he'll also understand he's got to
fucking stay off the ground.
You,
you,
you're,
you're not going to do well on the
ground one.
Nate Diaz,
he's just,
he's at a very,
very high level on the ground.
So unless connor gets way better with
his Jujitsu,
yeah.
By the time that fight takes place,
it's just keep the fight standing up.
Use a lot of leg kicks,
you any beats them.
And if you beat some,
if he beats him,
if he beats nate,
Diaz loses.
Yeah.
So if he loses,
he was gonna lose.
He might've lost a frankie.
I'm going to say he's going to,
but he could have lost all,
do a rematch,
anything could have happened.
And then that Nate Diaz money's gone.
See the Nate Diaz,
money's the big money.
He is the most famous guy along with
connor right now.
If he wins,
they're doing a 100% and they're all,
and then they give up that fucking title
at one 45 and get fucking rich.
I mean,
at some level,
if you're,
uh,
if you're a martial artist and emphasize
the artists,
give,
keep your fucking titles the way Chris
serone seems to think about it.
Well,
I'm just here to fight,
man.
You play whatever belt you want on me.
He certainly want that title.
So
yeah,
I feel what you're saying.
Yeah.
Um,
I think it's about money.
Weights,
you know,
I'm money fights are what's really
important and it's not a matter of
titles.
No one want to give a fuck if neither
nate Diaz doesn't have a title.
And conor mcgregor is not the
welterweight champion.
If he gave up his title,
that wouldn't mean a goddamn thing.
The war.
So great.
Former featherweight champion versus
former ultimate fighter winner who
stopped this guy in a second round of
their last fight.
It's a spectacular fight and the trash
is so good.
Oh,
it's a giant fight.
Steroids.
How you take that back?
All right.
Steroids.
Yeah,
it's a giant.
What have I ever done?
I've never done it.
Steroids.
Yeah,
so correct.
Nate and nate was an flap ton flappable,
but all of that last fight,
they were like,
you got to stop talking to the Reps.
Dot.
He's like,
why?
That's how I fight whatever fight in
stockton.
I fight.
You can't tell him to talk shit.
What do you mean is that a rental
referee needs to shut the fuck up.
It's not a rule.
You can't do that.
There's a lot stuff that referees,
referee's get a little busy in there.
Sometimes they they,
they interfere too much.
They talk too much fight.
Come on guys.
Fight.
Keep it moving.
Like when they are fighting.
Sometimes I say that like when guys are
clenching and they have a turncoat what?
Yeah,
there's some referees.
They're just not that good.
Oh,
right.
You know,
there's like,
there's guys that say it when it's
appropriate,
like herb dean will say it when it's
appropriate.
Like if someone's like,
they're stalling,
he's great.
He's a gold standard.
Him and mccarthy are the gold standard
to the best.
And uh,
Josh Rosenfeld,
I would tell you this,
I saw once at the Pearl,
I saw,
um,
her being called a fight and,
uh,
people were booing early stoppage,
early stoppage,
and I saw him walk out of the optic
octagon optic on it.
I saw him walking out of the octagon and
look at the replay and watch it.
I saw him watch it and then he sees the
replay go.
Yeah.
Like he was like,
I did the right thing.
Yeah.
He,
um,
he and I had a conversation after the
Tim Silvia fight.
Yeah.
Tim Silvia fought Frank Mir and the
audience is booing cause he stopped the
fight because they didn't see it.
But I saw it because I had the replay in
front of me and the spleen,
the audience didn't have a screen that
they could call it from the truck
instantly.
So they had to pull it up on the big
screen where you could see frank's arm
break.
Uh,
so,
or excuse me,
he see Tim's on break.
Yeah.
So frank got him in an arm bar and
snapped his forum in half,
and herb was right there and called it,
and the referee,
the audience was screaming Booboo,
booboo.
But when I got in there,
I go,
well,
what's going on?
I go,
it looks like it was broken.
He goes,
oh yeah,
I heard it.
It snapped.
And so then we played it back to the
audience and I said,
well,
watch this.
What's that?
I go,
that's a broken arm.
And then it showed it to,
uh,
Tim Silvia and Tim Sylvia,
thank [inaudible] herb dean after the
fight.
He's like,
I was complaining about the early
stoppage,
but you saved my career.
Like my fucking arm is broken in half.
And so herb was like,
here are,
you heard the snap saw the bone a lot
more damage than fucking with it or her
was in the perfect position.
He's a really good referees as far as
holiday.
I said,
thank yeah,
thank you for saving my career.
And finally his fucking arm man,
because if someone yanks on a compound
fracture and it goes right through the
skin and the bone birth,
he use all sorts of risk of infection.
The real serious complications.
I mean,
who knows if that arms ever going to be
the same again,
most exciting fight I might've ever seen
Tim Silvia Radica tour in Columbus.
[inaudible] verify first five they ever
had in Columbus,
right?
Not passed on the first round.
And then everyone was like,
what?
Yeah,
no,
he can't take the title.
Yeah,
that's all right.
One one round.
That's good.
And then went on the second round,
I was like,
dude,
if he wins one more round,
he'll win the decision.
Were any big brother to him?
Beat him five.
Oh.
And he,
he,
he stepped in with like the inside leg
kick fake to the big right hand and just
collaborate.
Tim Silvia.
And I think tim just totally never
recovered from that and it was probably
just caught him on the Chin and whopped
him.
Did you ever see Tim Sylvia when he
fought Ray Mercer?
Yeah.
Dude,
that was a crazy idea.
That was a crazy still fake.
The leg kick timmers like we're not
going to do it kicks right.
We're under the pussy.
Shit.
Fake the leg kick.
This is what was supposed to happen.
They were supposed to have a boxing
match.
It's supposed to be Raymar surface tim
silver with a boxing match.
But because Ray Mercer,
um,
was a world champion and Tim Silvia
didn't have any pro boxing matches,
the section isn't sanctioned.
So they had to make it mma,
which they say,
hey,
we both know we're just going to do
boxing.
And they'll be like,
yeah,
yeah.
Allegedly.
They agreed to that.
And then Tim Silvia leg kicked him and
Ray Mercer hit him with a haymaker from
hell.
It was a haymaker on steroids.
It was a knockout on crack.
Yeah.
Ray Marcia was a monster when he was
young.
He could hit a hard,
that's like the last thing that goes
away with a guy like him.
Here it is like,
see,
he gets kicked and he's like,
Oh fuck you mother fucker.
I think we talked about this.
And then he fucking big boy too.
Boom.
Look at that.
What does the six eight,
six,
10 yeah.
Oh,
he's enormous.
Yeah.
Oh,
he got slept.
Look,
watch this.
Punch womp.
That guy hits so hard for him to catch
you like that on the chin.
Well,
mercer,
he was awesome back in the day.
Ray Mercer was awesome.
Knock out a Tommy Morrison.
Did you ever see that?
No.
Tommy Gun,
God,
one of the most frightening knockouts in
the history of boxing through.
Sure.
Tommy Morrison was the guy.
He was the white hope.
Everybody thought he was going to be the
heavyweight champion.
He was in the rocky movie.
He was this bad ass and he fought
motherfucking Ray Mercer and Ray Mercer.
Boom.
He catches him with this shot and look
at this fucking combination.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
And Tommy gets caught up in the ropes
here going down.
Look,
his arm gets wrapped up in the ropes and
look at this.
Boom,
boom.
He's out.
Boom,
standing up.
The reps try to stop and he's caught.
He was caught in the road.
Should have been down,
dude.
It was brutal.
It's one of the worst Kaos ever and
Morrison came back from that,
but not really.
That's amazing.
He was always fucked up from that.
That fight was just devastating.
He got tired.
He the anxiety of the event and the fact
that ray mercer hit so hard,
you know,
you're always nervous.
You always scared and then he got
caught.
Bang started slowing down and got
Ray Mercer could close the fucking show
too.
Speaking of fights,
speaking of fights,
Greg Fitzsimmons is going to doing a
fight story in the next,
next season of this is not happening.
Oh,
are you a plugging,
plugging?
I didn't realize I was doing it,
but it is every Tuesday night you got
just three episodes left.
Didn't you just say you're going to be
some more soon doing standup comedy
perhaps this weekend by the thought
about Tempe,
Arizona at the Improv at Tempe Improv.
What I place the great.com you go to our
website one oh five the zoo.
If you enter in your email address,
you can win tickets to see Irish.
A fair.
Alright.
Most likely we'll just said no.
Yo,
this is for sure you guys.
You can dvr the show for sure.
I'd like you to do that.
Rod Whites on this week with me during
that story about Chinese
shit squat toilet.
Oh Nice.
Yeah.
I worked it into like a long nice story
bias.
If you google or youtube search,
this is not happening.
Playlist.
You'll see the unedited versions of
these long form stories.
71 videos up right now.
Diaz has probably four of them.
That's beautiful.
Rogan has to us all out,
man at the Improv lab and side,
bro.
12 people.
Bella.
Donna was one of them.
Bella,
Donna.
She wasn't the audience.
Whatever happened to her.
She looked tired.
She got out of the business.
I don't really come across porn hub
anymore.
They just get out of the businessman.
But yeah.
But yeah,
I started with nothing Diaz and Marin
was in the first one.
Did you start from the bottom?
Now you're here.
I guess so.
I guess
now the whole crew's here.
That's might be true.
I think that really holds true.
I mean,
it's an arguable this point,
dawn and from the bottom.
Now we're here.
This is not in three weeks in the season
finale.
So a cyborgs in the UFC now too.
That's amazing.
I just heard that from you.
We're open pool.
Yeah.
Finally,
finally.
Yeah.
At one 41 40 fights it.
35 yes.
And she's going to fight Leslie Smith
who fights at one 35 she's the girl at
her ear exploded or here got torn off by
Jessica.
I,
what's the problem?
Well,
it's not a problem,
but it's a one 40 pound weight class
instead of a one 45 that's the one 45 is
what she's champion of and Invicta.
And I think the idea is that they
worried that they don't have enough 145
pound talent.
I think they didn't have enough hunted
know for sure they didn't have 115 pound
town.
Some of the third about to give somebody
a third rematch in five years.
Like,
come on man,
what you mean we should tape?
It was like you don't have a deep enough
weight class if that's what you keep
doing.
Well sort of,
but I mean that's the same problem
they're going to have right now at
welterweight.
The same problem you were talking about
at one 45,
which has a lot of talent.
There's a lot of town at one 45 and
men's.
Oh yeah.
You know,
so this is what I think.
I think,
uh,
first of all she's fucking terrifying to
talk about like one of the scariest
female strikers in mma,
cyborgs terrifying.
And Tony and I got in trouble because
we,
uh,
said some inappropriate jokes about what
would a roast be like with her.
All jokes aside.
Even before that I had tweeted that a,
I would love to see her in the UFC for
sure.
The name,
she's a monster.
And I think also we shouldn't have
double standards as far as who takes
performance enhancing drugs,
whether it's for men or for women.
Like it was like things are kind of is,
I think the way people look at it,
like what a woman is taking testosterone
versus a man taking testosterone.
Yeah.
But you know,
honestly,
like some of the things that men have
been caught with have been pretty
unnatural as well.
Like super human levels of testosterone
that don't even exist in medical books,
you know?
So it's,
you could argue that it's dangerous
because a woman does change her anatomy,
whatever.
They're testing her now.
Yeah,
but your anatomy changes.
Oh,
right.
But you have to make a weight class.
It's,
it's tricky,
man.
I mean it always seen before this holly
Holm things happened and that's all
fishy too.
What's fishy?
Rhonda won't take a fight.
I'll take a fight against Holly Holm and
then it's suddenly like Misha tate when
it's like,
I'm ready to fight now.
It's like,
oh no.
She's not necessarily ready to fight
now.
No,
she,
she's not.
She can't find until like November.
She was really,
she has,
she's got movie obligations.
They got moved around.
See that's bad right there.
When the movies get in the way of your
fights,
like you got to pick one or the other.
Go in between.
Yeah.
I,
as soon as my fights over,
I can do your movie for the next three
months and then I got her back to
training.
It's gotta be hard though when you're a,
you know,
a super celebrity and you're getting all
this love and everybody wants to put you
in all these different things.
It's gotta be hard to say no to certain
things obviously.
But the same shit happens.
A female comics.
Yeah,
but it's way worse with a fighter
because a fighter has to be physically
tuned up to go in to do battle and get
kicked in the fucking way.
We're sort of fighter.
It's just similar where it's like you're
not concentrating on the thing that got
you there.
So the thing that got you there is now
suffering.
Maybe you don't care anymore.
Maybe you just want to do movies.
Okay,
well that happens to a lot of comics
when they,
they make it,
all the sudden you start getting movie
offers and TV show offers up.
Sucks.
Yeah.
You're um,
you got to spend time in the trenches.
I'll work out for two weeks before my
special.
I was like,
oh no,
you can't do that.
I had a conversation with a guy was on a
TV show about that.
It was telling me he was doing a
special,
I'm like,
what?
When are you doing?
He's like,
Saturday night,
I'm going to,
I knew he had been doing like one or two
sets a week.
It's like,
whoa.
Hmm.
All right.
Yeah.
Like what are you doing?
She wants Julian one or two headlines
that's a week.
It's not like he's doing one or two
theaters a week just doing spots.
It's crazy.
That's a lack of respect for the art
form.
Well,
it's not no herself.
Not Knowing,
not having done it,
you know,
not,
not often done it the right way where
you feel better and everything's loose.
You know,
you think I'm doing well,
my sets are going well.
We've all made the stringing together an
hour,
four minutes.
Yeah.
I mean you can,
it's just to do it the right way,
like the way,
um,
I think gives it the most time to grow.
You have to have material that you've
worked on for a long time and you have
to put a lot of effort into it and then
you have to tighten that shit down and
get a really great comedy shape for
about two months.
That's what I think.
I think you need two solid months of
every weekend.
Smashing it every weekend.
Two shows,
Friday,
two shows,
Saturday show on Sunday.
Do spouts during the week.
And you know what dude?
We feel asked me what's the best show to
watch.
And I was like,
I don't know.
They're all the same.
But if it's my first time on the road,
even in two weeks,
that the Thursday show,
that first show of the week is not going
to be the best show.
It depends though.
It depends.
Sure I could get loose and have fun
doing during the week and how excited
you are to be in San Francisco and if I
just performed a Thursday through
Sunday,
the week before,
so this is the only three days later.
Right.
Y'All can be sharp.
But if it's been a few weeks and it's
like,
but by Saturday of that week,
oh I'm on fire.
And there's a big difference between
doing Thursday night.
If you are coming off of a weekend run
of like three,
five weekends in a row and you're on
fire like one of a whenever.
One of the times,
the only time I've ever gone on a real
tour was when I did that thing with
Charlie Murphy and half Ron and we did
that real men of comedy maximum thing
that that thing,
man,
we did 22 or 23 dates and you're just
doing show after show after show after
show.
Oh,
you get like a,
like a fucking Samurai sword,
man.
The blade just gets folded down and
polished.
And now imagine if you took off half
those days to go shoot a movie,
how would your final shows up on most of
those days?
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
It's no way,
but it's like everything else.
Everything else.
I mean,
you don't become a world champion
fighter without dedicating your life to
it.
You don't become a great musician
without a lot of rehearsal and a lot of
planning.
How much you're going to prep before
your,
uh,
how many weeks in a row before your next
special you're gonna go,
what are you going to do?
No less than no less than eight weeks.
Well,
first of all,
never t I'm not,
I've taken like vacations or it took a
vacation last week,
which I wrote when I was on vacation.
Sometimes I think those vacation plans,
yeah,
but sometimes I think those vacation
times where I know I'm not going to
perform it,
I just write my thoughts down with no
pressure just to fuck around.
And I get ideas.
I get little seeds that grow from those
sort of,
you know,
those,
those introspective sit down moments on
the beach be presented right now.
So you have to tap this,
that doesn't have to be presented to an
audience right now.
So you have two or three days to form
your thoughts fully and really go into
it five days a week,
whatever it is.
My point being,
um,
I'm constantly working,
like I'm not taking any time off besides
like having a little vacation time.
Even when I had a vacation,
I came back and I did,
I gave back on my vacation on Thursday
night and I was performing Friday and
Saturday night and went right back in,
you know,
and I'm doing two,
three shows a night.
I'm doing them a different clubs and
moving around and then I'm gonna run the
road.
I think you,
you've got to stay sharp.
You gotta,
you gotta bear down.
But the last run I accept no less than
two months,
but every week.
Yeah.
And on the road every week somewhere.
It doesn't have to be on the road.
It can be the Irvine Improv.
It could be Ontario do an hours.
Yes.
So you're saying seven straight weeks
and then fill them on the eighth.
Yeah.
And you're not going to take I sometimes
I thought,
I don't know if I should like take the
week off before.
So then when Thursday comes wherever I'm
doing a cap city in October.
But like when I,
when I do have a little freshness to it,
you could do that.
I don't know the right way.
And I also want to do like a garbage
club the week before that
c level room where I won't have fans and
I can just like,
let me test,
let me failure where you go as long as
you put it online and dealer fans,
daisy just lower percentage,
just like I don't have a drug as people,
you know,
he felt for Ted Cruz,
you know those people,
they're not on the coast.
Um,
I don't know man.
I think it's different for everybody.
So you're going to do eight straight
weeks.
That's great.
You're going to be,
so you're going to be fire.
I think you have to,
I think you could also like,
um,
during the weekdays I got to do like ice
house sets and or Tuesday night.
No,
but like do not just store sets but do
long sets during the week too.
He's got to hammer it down man.
And you,
you'll know,
you'll know if you're burning,
you know,
if you're not feeling that good about it
and you'll know if it's,
it's,
you know,
you're feeling good.
But I think,
um,
I dunno man.
It's exciting stuff.
Yeah,
you're a
correct whatever.
Fucking just the fire math or fire.
I'm into it right now.
Really into it.
Loving it,
man.
And other thing is coming back to the
store,
which has been a little over a year now.
You know,
I feel it though.
Fuck.
Love it.
Very happy.
Perfect move.
It feels like it's being away from.
It was great.
It's your home.
You were at war for a while or something
that you got back home and everything's
normal again.
That's better.
It's better than young crop is better.
E Bay has completely changed,
changed the game,
reached out to people like foot.
And Hannibal and just be like,
hey,
whatever the system was,
here's the number to call and call and
every Monday we were one of the best
comics in the country.
Just come,
come on.
Adam came to get me.
Well I came by it.
Why me?
I came,
I wanted to go by there again for two
reasons.
One,
because you were doing your special
there.
I knew it had to be there,
so I was like,
okay,
thank you.
That meant a lot to me.
Yeah,
I had to,
I was like,
I'm not going to like that.
It was a huge deal.
Like you getting your first comedy
central special and you know me being
your friend from when you were a
doorman.
Yeah.
Door Guy,
dude.
You know you have a comedy central
special and it's filming at the store.
You know,
I was going pretty excited so I decided
to go the day before for that so I came
down on,
it wouldn't be like during the special
like Oh my God,
I chose to get a lot of the work I had
to go like just relax.
The fact that I was there.
So I went to roast battle and I was
like,
wow,
the vibe of this place is crazy.
I was like,
this is so much better than it was
before.
It just,
it's,
the young crop is so much better.
That roast battles insane.
They've empowered.
Emily has empowered like the door
guides,
buck.
If you can come up with a show and you
can get some people there,
I'll give you the belly room.
Yup.
Just come up with a show.
I'm looking for you guys to like make
instead of before.
We're like Mitzi,
he'll never let us do anything.
Yeah,
no,
it's a totally different animal.
It's just way better.
And it's also,
we've been talking about this,
that there's people now that became
comedy fans because of the Internet from
Youtube clips and from podcasts,
and they understand it now and they know
that that's the place where we fuck
around and work out and they know that
we're going to be there all the time.
You'd be audience members.
Yeah.
So you build it and they'll come like,
you go there now it's fucking mob mob.
Wednesday.
It's mom's on a Tuesday,
Monday,
the open mic show,
the employee show,
they're like,
it's packed there.
Cause one of the only times you can get
a free show at the comedy store too,
they sold out 20 nights in the or in a
row and the or.
Okay.
And people understand what this means
since it's only,
maybe it's not,
it's 165 seats.
But when I ran
the cover booth,
there were Tuesdays and Wednesdays
consistently.
You couldn't start with less than six
people.
And we wouldn't start shows was start
nine.
We wouldn't start till like 10 cause we
put and get six people in there.
Yeah,
it'd be nobody there six now.
And now it's just
knowing that those times were only,
I mean less than a decade ago was like,
wow,
the internet changed.
The game.
Son Changed the whole game and podcasts
changed the game.
Everybody's got a Goddamn podcast that
you're gonna get some fans pills or mark
Marin.
I mean,
Mark Marin's entire fame is based on a
podcast.
He didn't get fame from anything.
I mean a little bit from that,
uh,
America show.
But that was all kind of gone.
Yeah,
he had a small base,
but that's very,
that's how he's got now.
Yeah.
No,
I mean now he's famous in America.
He's famous and he's famous because of
the Internet,
because of podcasting.
Al madrigals there.
You know what I mean?
It's like
here's what's an amazing thing.
It overthrew a fucking government in
Libya and an and an Egypt.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The Internet is a motherfucker,
dude.
It's a motherfucker and so the place is
what it should have always been.
It's the like the best like playground
for comics,
whatever you want,
fuck around,
come up with great material and men,
Oh my God folks,
if you're in town on a night where Brian
Holtzman is closing out the main room,
just go.
I mean this is not,
it's not become a thing yet.
It should be a thing like when people
are talking about like Kennison his
prime.
I came in late.
Yeah,
it was all late night.
I'm telling you,
Bryan Holtzman on Friday night,
he got on stage at like,
you know like 12 o'clock 1230 or
something like that.
Three and a half hours into the show.
It's a long show.
If that's the main road that there were
300 people in there,
there's probably 30 at this point.
Well,
there's more and more now.
That's what's interesting.
There was like 60 or 70 so that people
know that it's happening now because
then as the show goes off forever.
So if you just,
if you finish your bar at fucking 1130,
you can just roll in.
I'm telling you,
he got a second half of it.
He's a fucking animal.
He is so funny.
And Brian is a guy that was there when I
first arrived in [inaudible] 94
it'll help Mitzi found him.
She was in her office upstairs.
Remember that old office up there and
uh,
there's a door you can still see.
It's kind of sealed up into the belly
room from her office.
She heard somebody killing and she was
like,
well,
what is this?
She just kind of listened through the
door and she opened it up and it was
Holtzman offstage.
Wow.
Get him over here.
Yeah.
And like a bringer show type thing,
like a,
you know,
an open mic type thing.
Just one of my favorite comedians.
He's mean,
he almost made me Barf once.
Like I was laughing so hard,
I couldn't even control it.
I want to do any of this.
He was
material,
but [inaudible] has been about,
uh,
Hillary Clinton.
Yeah.
You can't use it.
Literally.
So singular and anger he brings to it
and,
and the,
I mean,
when Charlie's angels came out,
they used to,
uh,
ashtrays at the comedy store.
Big fucking thick glass ones.
I mean thick and big.
I mean the size of this alarm clock.
I remember those things.
Eventually I got the plastic ones,
but they had them up there.
It's only for the comedians to smoke.
Right.
If they want it to.
Cause if you did and he goes,
he's childish.
I don't like that movie because it gets
women the false impression that they can
defend themselves.
I am a 220 pound former crack addict,
former marine.
I will.
And it takes the fucking ashtray.
Oh,
he just slams it.
I will close it.
And it just shatters.
He destroyed a giant glass ashtray
onstage and it's,
you would say,
that's not funny.
That's scary.
He's talking about beating women that
you have to see it.
It's a character,
but in,
he'll break character occasionally and
giggle and laugh,
and then he goes back into it.
Fuck Dude.
The lack of,
put your heads down if you don't want to
live in the jungle,
but your eyes,
he almost,
he would do sometimes bad jokes,
like real stock jokes so he could get
mad at the crap for not laughing at
them.
Knocks doctors,
just his own stock jokes.
Right.
So He'd get mad at the craft or not the
jump.
So we can go off.
Yeah.
Well,
he just wants to be angry,
but it's fucking great.
Anyway.
Yeah.
Comedy store.
It's awesome.
That's it folks.
We've got to bring this pitch home.
I gotta go work for the UFC.
I got some counties do.
I'm going to find out some secrets you
find out about some fights,
some shit nobody knows about.
Ooh.
So excite,
Cyborg rousy.
Everybody wants to see that.
Yeah.
Well that's got to happen after cyborg
fights.
Leslie Smith.
That's in May in Brazil and Brazil.
Yeah.
Um,
that's it.
You fucks.
We'll be back tomorrow with Andrew Dice.
Clay,
Holla at your boy for excite x and a
until then,
um,
Ari,
anything to say to the people guys,
uh,
I guess not.
Okay.
Go Fuck yourself from Rsu fear,
dvr on my show.
This is not happening.
Tuesday night slash Wednesday morning at
1230 on comedy central.
We've got three episodes left and Diaz
is on one of them and Sean Pad until
maybe the best story of the year,
the last episode and Simone's on in two
weeks.
Ron White's on this week with me.
Beautiful.
All right folks.
See you soon.
Much love.
Bye.